[Music]
[Music]
yo
realm what is going on
talk to me out there frodo i see you
what's going on
brian mota what's going on man welcome
to the lord's
day sunday you already know what time it
is benjamin mumma
what's going on should be an exciting
day in the realm today yes yes
let me know my levels of sounding
johanna dark what's going on
talk to me by you hayabusa david oros
who's been very spicy because his
pirate's been winning
so i know he's feeling himself right now
yo
hustle my guy audio's good thank you sir
thank you sir
trying to get that the levels right oh
hustle back in there
that's what's up man yo put the crest
off for hustle man he holds us
down nick's nine the tcl boys stand
you try to start your own crew ttl boys
what we doing next
no doubt yo jimbo what's going on
yeah david all right that's right you're
being less spicy to me i like that
what's going on should be a good one
firestarter you already know lloyd
metroid what's going on
should be a fun little podcast well not
little should be a big one today we got
some surprises
you know what i mean uh shout out make
sure y'all send um adding some love man
real rough week and you know he said
he's gonna make it but if he can't
it's all good you know what i'm saying
so for those who didn't know you know
rest in peace to
addicts pops you know what i mean and um
very sudden
and like i said we his brothers so we're
here to support him in any way we need
and if he needs time we give him that if
he wants to come through
he come through you know what i mean so
that's that soft might be joining us
coming in hot and of course the kings
will pull up and spoke to the king
earlier so um yeah
that's what we got yeah definitely put
the crest up
you know what i'm saying for attic once
you come in show i need addict to get
some extra love today man
for real so yeah that's what i got six
layer what's going on bro
yeah that's what i got we're gonna let
everybody get into the room
get the congregation going collect the
plate
pass the collection i'm just joking
yeah oh matt jiminez addicted oh thank
you brother first time in here on time
so
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be a fun
one we got some very
spicy topics to discuss for sure
you know what i mean so anyway i'm gonna
let people file in
and uh yeah i will definitely get back
to y'all and get the lords in here get
ready for some fun on the lord's
day you already know talk to you in a
[Music]
minute
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't wanna be on the song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
on twitter but i'm anti-social love my
city but i'm still by coastal
i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell the uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you
hear you man welcome to the show if you
would not mind go ahead and uh find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until the time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't wanna be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department
um
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on the song with
me that's understandable i kill a beat
and they want to compare me to freddie
and jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all so
i know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire's flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to
[Music]
um
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
and turn me to an animal and headless be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on the song with
me that's understandable i kill a beat
and they want to compare me to freddie
and jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man
welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they're
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beating
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beating
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
[Music]
look coastal guess you could say that
i'm very spoiled to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger that's
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i am well it's not important who
i am
uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh i guess i'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that
this is their up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
rings you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
check my vote on twitter but i'm
anti-social
[Music]
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh i guess i'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing that real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being a
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's let's do that
again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city
[Music]
you ain't got to say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger that's
[Music]
chill and watch them any snacks in the
attic i wanted to chill with the pack
and be like a young wolf but then they
would mistake me for addict if i can
imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be meadow
i know it's my destiny worth the cognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that jew king
david still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible wasn't it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursued but whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right hear ye hear ye
and we are live welcome
to the iron lords podcast llc and the
lords of gaming.net
episode number 217 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day
and today we've got the steam deck
reveal we'll say stream deck
it's like so close to it steam deck
reveal
easy difficulty reviews xbox series x
npd and netflix gaming to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
so let's introduce the well we missed it
one lord
shout out to uh lord soft hopefully will
join us in progress got called into work
a little emergency situation but we
still got three lords of the realm
those three horsemen and original lords
of the realm of the round table
and first my co-host with the cole most
my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the heart
of the young wolf my man so
glad he could make it lord addict how we
doing sir
doing pretty good uh we're gonna we'll
get to the super chats here in a couple
minutes i saw we
we just said it i'm sure some of you are
coming in so we'll
hopefully be coming in late he got
called into work at the last minute
but we we have some good cameos for you
guys too so stick around for that
yes and yes i will be streaming
uh skyward sword tomorrow no doubt
i booted it up just to play a couple
minutes and i was like this is like got
an 82.
i'm so so happy uh you can make it
obviously we know
you had a rough week and um like i said
i know you would have been
totally okay if you couldn't but i saw
your tweet and um
they're kind of like my dad which is he
got me my first console you know what
i'm saying got me into gaming so
if you don't mind there's a couple of um
super chats for you sir and i wanted you
yeah we'll go ahead and read through
super chats we got five dollar super
chat from mr jonah dark
to laura addict my thoughts and prayers
go out to you i know the feeling of
losing a parent i lost my dad to coven
and my mom to cancer in 2021 i
appreciate it you guys um
we got another five dollar super chat
from mr jonah dark
uh do you think it's better for xbox or
partner with val
by making xbox game pass app compatible
versus
making their own dedicated handheld what
i do should you
carry i'm pretty sure we'll answer that
in uh
here in a couple of moments that's the
first topic we got a five dollar super
chat from tony brandt attic my
condolences go out to you truly losing a
parent is never easy and i am one glad
you
have your iop brothers we are here for
you i appreciate all the kind words guys
we got another five dollar subscribe
from smitty smith you are not alone lord
adams we are here for you brother
definitely appreciate
the support guys salute gonna put you
your name but we we
moved past we got so i got to fight all
super chat from
tazzaku
i i was close sup lords in chat thank
you all for the support through the hard
times for me i'll
try to listen to the podcast later but
it's hard to take care yeah listen hold
on let's
real quickly shout out to which he's
also going through
a tough loss you know so he put it up on
twitter and um
you know good yeah he definitely put up
on twitter and and who he lost
um definitely was was a fan of iron
lord's podcast as well so
please please please link me in it so
because he's heavily supported in
anything that i've done
and um i don't want him to think that
i've overlooked in taizuichi
whenever you get a chance to see this uh
my heart and my prayers go out to you
and your family
you know i do apologize i didn't get a
chance to see it no no doubt no doubt he
understands that
and what else we got uh
good afternoon realm have a curveball
cog everyone needs to watch
the dragon quest anime on hula
it's amazing shonen and doesn't slow
down
yeah i got there's a drag i mean
obviously i think there's a blue dragon
anime too
but oh i saw that no i was obviously
yeah so it was a joke i'll definitely
have to try that out right now
i have a couple different uh animations
i'm doing resident evil right now on
netflix
i couldn't i couldn't get down on that i
could i couldn't i watched five minutes
if it was like this animation ain't it
okay yo for me
i was like oh this is great i was like
i was like leon kennedy
about all of this i'm done of the shout
out to flame for not being messy because
i know how he does
we still got another one for flame um
let's see it jumped up again it's cool
it's for you we got a two dollar
superstar from playing i'm clearly in a
podcast zachary
we got a two dollar super drive from
flame also addicts stay strong brother
definitely appreciate it
we got a two superchat from rrd
i want to play ten i want to pay ten
dollars for
an iceland lip sync in hellblade you
know what that is
glad you can make it to the show i lost
my earlier this year and iopu was always
there for me
keep your head up i'm always here for
you appreciate it forte
we got a three dollar super chat from
the list 22 attic present condolences to
you and your family
we'll be uh halting the super chats
probably uh for a couple of minutes
no doubt no doubt and uh oh and hustle
and motivate join the realm so
definitely
oh yeah
working very hard behind the scenes yes
uh please
put uh the crest up yeah support him man
definitely he holds it down so of course
like i said alex i'm glad he can make it
and uh lord solve like i said hopefully
hopefully will be joining us in progress
but until then we got a special message
for the realm you know we want to do
something special
so i'm not going to talk too much or
we're going to let this play and uh
hopefully you guys understand soon as we
come back
[Music]
peace and blessings uh i bring you
great news you know a lot of times uh
we're talking about video games or we're
talking about combat sports we're
talking about wonderful statues today
i'm talking to you about
life i'm talking to you about the stuff
that matters
most to parents right
the stuff that matters most to parents
is their children
the seed of their loins
[Music]
the fruit from the tree
and what parents want for their children
or what every parent should want for
their children is for their children to
succeed
at the highest level ever since my
daughter's been born
i changed the way i did things that i
changed the way i thought
i changed the way i operated
to fit around this wonderful new life
that was in my life and
she did such a phenomenal job
growing up to the adult that she is
now when she graduated
i was elated when she was born i was
elated
i had purpose
[Music]
she has always been a shining light a
great kid and she started out
on her first job
but let's back it up just a little bit
she wants to be like a dad
a entrepreneur go out
start your own business be the captain
of your own ship
so she has a love for baking
and she's going to the culinary
institute of america
i'm so ecstatic she graduated with a 4.0
gpa
and she's going
to do and follow her dreams she says
daddy
she wants to own home bakery she loves
to make cupcake cakes and
yes we are the guinea pigs yes
we try everything and we encourage her
and push her through so now she has her
first job
and she works for cutco
she's doing her passion
cut cut cove sells
fine cutlery and
it's amazing of course she would be
doing something
that is linked to what
she truly is to become
[Music]
so this is where you guys come in and
this is where i need you guys
help because
we all want our children to succeed
because i was one of her uh clients
so what you do is you go to your
iphone or your google app
and you go and you download cutco
and her reference number was that number
that you saw the whole time
that was up at the top and you go and
you put in her reference number
and do me a favor schedule interview
sit down even if you don't buy anything
she's working on her
skills that she would need to succeed in
life
conversational skills selling skills
being endeared to the customer type of
skills
she's working on skills that will
forever
better herself so please
take the time out do that
and you're doing me a favor you're doing
us
a favor but you're also helping her
build
and succeed in life and it's all
we want as parents thank you again it's
lord king david
giving you a little bit something
different
than just what we do when we do our
hobbies
these are our hobbies she's my life
[Music]
peace all right
special special announcement by the
realm
so we gotta introduce the lord behind it
of course the excess gamer himself
the incredible hulk of this my man lord
king the prophet how are we doing sir
i'm just gonna go straight to it
thank you man i
[Laughter]
first i um like this this whole
week i just was trying to you know keep
on reaching out to attic
yeah and um you know because my heart
goes out to him
um and i love this guy i love him the
deaf
on on a non-personal note but also a
loss
in general um and in for other people
you know his songs
may have been personal to them we lost
biz markey
yeah uh og pioneer um in the hip-hop
world
um and you know this kind of sucks
because we're
we're losing them by the bucket fulls
and you know
health is wealth people you know just uh
make sure you take care of yourself and
if you find out something
trust me that cheeseburger or whatever
it is that you're going to eat is not
worth your life
if you put it down just say just forget
it but not saying that's his situation
and not saying that i know his situation
i'm just telling people
you know just health is worth oh but
let's let's let's let's let's pump it up
because
we came in on some good music let's
let's pump it up
the fight last night though how about
that dude yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta
talk to me i i need to catch it but you
gotta talk to me okay
so yeah charlo versus um
dog man
uh uh uh brian chanston i believe
uh um it was an epic fight
you had one dude that was that was
coming from fighting out of the gutter
that was trying to he and he's a
champion undefeated
was trying to reach the stars and you
had uh
established champion that you know has
his three belts that had to get out of
satin sheets
to come off his throne you know always
what it up
yeah to go down and and me
i know he felt it in this manner meet
this
mere peasant how dare he attack
well shout out to the peasant for going
it hard
listen paul's 100 of the
fight this man gave his heart his soul
throughout the fight and um
i the reason why i'm not remembering his
name right now because
the video got they say castano castano
yeah thank you
all right um and like listen he gave
100 to charlo and and you notice
i i said this when i'm watching it first
before the fight was called i knew it
was going to be a draw
and i said they're going to fight again
in december um because this fight needs
to have a definitive winner
right uh you had castano fighting
past his potential and you had
charlo not fighting to his potential
got you that's why you got a draw uh it
was punches there that i saw
that he was supposed to throw that he
didn't throw
and he didn't throw these punches
because castano didn't let him
all right let's not get it twisted that
uppercut was not coming out because
castano
wasn't allowing him to be comfortable in
his space
but when you're in the ring and you're
doing a one-two
it's because that's the only thing you
feel safe with
you understand so it was times when
charlo could have knocked him out he had
him um
three times he had him badly injured but
couldn't finish it
it went 12 rounds estanyo didn't deserve
to lose
and charlo didn't deserve to lose so i
was happy with the draw but this is what
happens when you sleep in shot and
sheets
uncomfortable gucci slippers on
the gucci egg the flip-flops yeah well
he didn't have the conor mcgregor's
kind of shout out to mcgregor his ankles
i saw them in aruba last week
yeah blessed savage but it was a hell of
a fight and i was so happy i got a
chance to watch that
no doubt no doubt have you got a chance
to play any games this week sir oh
of course of course so none of them was
skyward sword oh
okay downloaded it all right attic and
attic is like
picked up yes excuse you
i downloaded it and my um physical copy
comes today from amazon
so i double dipped on this yeah on the
product for the amiibo
sir so just yes sir i'm just i'm not
waiting for the people
you bought it twice to not play it
before the hard copy
yeah yeah no no no i i hear exactly what
you're saying but shout out but you
won't find nothing that's not on gamepad
shout out shout out to game pass
you know what he's gonna do he's gonna
he's going to
twist it in a way i'm able to do that
because of games
yeah of course of course i mean well i
buy a lot of stuff off of game pass but
i buy it when you know the value of the
stuff drops down
because you don't have to buy in the
beginning and if you you know
wait around it'll fall to the price that
you like and you still get that 10
off so shout out to me for winning
yeah and when they about to go out the
door because they give you that notice
remember the thing you love
it's about to leave oh really let me
keep that
oh remember the thing you love that you
finished and yeah let that go thank you
but i'm playing blood root blood this is
crazy
i got a chance to play with my son
uh and um out riders nice so this is the
first time we played in outriders he's
in our chat
and he can hear us in the chat you know
it was like 12 people in our chat
and we were spread out in groups doing
outright and stuff his first expedition
with me he gets a death shield
hmm okay doing that people left the chat
they were tight people loved it i've
been playing this game since day one
and i still haven't got it that's that's
the exotic talk like yeah
i got you yes yes so yeah um it's nice
when it's on your side
but it sucks when it's not on your side
yes because then you start i guess
i got the um the rocket launcher
oh that right oh yeah it was like
the first like month i had it and people
[ __ ] people
people fought for that for months and i
i've done
vault of glass probably like 15 times
and i still ain't got the facts you
ain't missing that right now
it defects until they buff it you ain't
missing that
yeah but shout out to the dude who got
it yeah absolutely yeah shout out to
a shout out today shout out shout out to
cog who has it yeah
yeah you know god bless that's what it
sir yeah
and um you know just that's about it and
and my dragon quest i'm really mad at it
uh when it comes to this game because i
don't know
what type of inhuman person you are sir
oh he's
beast i don't i don't know i don't
people really don't know who the hell
you are
about them games finished it i've been
playing this game
every day for the past how many months
this has been added it's been like two
months right almost two months close
yeah i'm up to gold
yeah you know what i'm talking about
when i say gold i'm up to gold
mm-hmm atticus
the gold shore yeah no i'm no i'm up to
gold like you know when when gold is a
problem
right he got
just message me on facebook so like yeah
like
i i i need to know has like sir has it
turned dark that's what i need
oh yeah well i already did that we
already already got the team back
together and eric
oh okay okay okay now i know where yeah
oh you're talking about i now know what
the shore
the shore yeah i know what you're
talking about actually that
that boss in that gold placement that
was that was that was rough
like oh okay i was almost maxed out and
that that person like
was like i don't care about your backs
out
doing dallas for that sir yeah that
that's it
no doubt and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord cognito spreading that realism
around the iop not telling what you want
to hear but what you need
to hear last word with ibontis thai guy
travis had my man
above on yo above his dope man
definitely great great content creator
very very knowledgeable or high-end
content you know what i'm saying so we
had some good debates
talk about sunset and some great destiny
discussion so check that out it's up for
iop
you know what i'm saying speak of the
devil
again once again cog acting like he
didn't know like he was what a surprise
wow how did this happen
the legendary we got it we got to start
shutting those
we got to start it's it's like we just
walk into the podcast we're not like
locking the door
oh we got a lot to do with driving
right on cue it i was talking about that
amazing last word
we did with ibontis yesterday man
how you doing friday excuse me how are
we doing travis how are you doing sir
i'm doing great man uh fellow vic met
the class holder
yes yes oh my god flex
but uh got it on my first roll my first
round are you serious they did yeah yeah
no salute to him man but yeah i got him
i felt the room
even your friends your friends just got
really quiet
yeah that's what i have everybody
because only one p person see the exotic
that's at the chest
and you know who got it when you see it
at the bottom yeah it's a it's a very
set solve looks different yeah yeah yeah
yo
they said sovereign look different soft
turned white somehow i don't know
listen um in my defense i did do like 57
runs of eyes of tomorrow uh before i got
that
yeah yeah you definitely had a while for
that but uh yeah with me other than that
man because i've been doing my i
finished my destiny grind i got my
solstice
about to order my shirt did that um got
sidetracked for my mass effect 2 goat
greatness stuff i want to shout out my
uh defining duke co-host
maddie we were talking about like a
little in the cut games and i didn't
know he was a phantom doctrine game like
me
a doctor god yeah so i had to boot it up
get my little espionage a little
cold war spy you know what i mean so i
was doing that but um yeah that's been
pretty much
it for me but as far as you travels are
what have you been playing
i know you've had a you had a review up
there sir but i don't know it
has been planned yeah uh it's been
pretty much
all reviews and previews work um i did
two previews a review last week for ign
all in the same week uh so i spent like
50 hours
with uh um skyward sword hd for the
switch
yeah yeah gave it gave it an 8 out of 10
which i think it
probably should have gotten back in 2011
but that's neither here
um
because you was reviewing it back then i
did not review it no not you i'm talking
i'm talking about
it look look this is before youtube man
i didn't care about no
matter what it got a uh 10 out of 10.
[Music]
right there proves that nintendo has a
curve wait wait time my time out you got
10 out of 10 back then
wow oh then okay they was right
it was right there that travis right now
and it was wrong now
it was right there in my back i'm saying
that they were that he was wrong now it
should have it should have gotten an 8
out of 10 in 2011.
or i probably would have given a seven
back in 2011. okay
yeah i mean but anyway the guy who
wrote the review i don't know him i'm
sure he's a nice guy but he does work at
nintendo now so
gotcha oh look at him moving along
[Laughter]
let's get into this poll we got a poll
from last week last week's poll results
are in
and the people have spoken this was the
patreon poll shout out to selectbang007
here put this up so in regards to the
release of battlefield 2042
by ea at the potential of game pass
which answer closely mirrors your
thought process on purchase
the winner at 53 percent of the vote was
70 dollars no campaign and multiplayer
only makes it a wait for game
pass group coming in at second at close
41 percent of the vote was battlefield
looks amazing day one by
i'm not waiting for game pass and then
last place
at four percent was the messy lords i
don't care
we all know when big cod come through
it's all over for battlefield
so shout out to all the lords who
participated in the poll
um lord king the realm seems to agree
with you that they're going to wait for
game pass it was close but some say
they're gonna wait
well you got your chain up so what's up
battlefield
they're kicking you know what they're
not waiting for game pass
see you not though but the masters have
spoken
our community with the pole that's the
masses guys well listen listen i'm just
listening
let's get started let's get someone like
hey
what let's get someone like uh what's
the dude that does uh jeff keeley let's
get him to make a poll and then let's
let's see the masses he's trying to say
jeff keeley polo is better than albert
i'm saying i'm saying our paul gonna
have a couple hundred he's gonna have
like
20 30 000. but my hundred is real though
can you dig it get your warriors on
no doubt so kick you you all for that oh
you know right now mm-hmm he's got 100
people buying cutco knives
for real shout outs i'm one of them yes
sir
what's up listen man
game pass is the way people understand
that but the game ain't complete to be
honest with you
so if they're not gonna give you a
campaign because i'm a campaign type of
dude
uh and you're gonna you know short
change i'll just wait for game pass to
play it
being that that's one of the games that
i know you guys gonna want to see us
play
we can't really wait regardless to what
happens i still have hope
at the end of the day microsoft will put
it in game pass i think for that game to
have
life that it should be in game pass i
don't know if they're going to be able
to work out the deal
up until that day um but again
those that would wait because the game
isn't complete or they didn't see
something that they actually wanted
yeah all right fine game pass is the
venue but again
we're going to be forced to play this to
be honest with you and i
love playing that game with my friends
so i can't wait for the game to come out
um regardless if it's game pass or if
it's not uh but if it's game pass
i already know you're going there all
right i already know you go with it but
anyway moving on man we gotta jump into
these topics we got a lot to discuss but
um
yeah looks like valve is in the news
valve announces the steam deck 400
handheld gaming pc shout out to igna it
was a
first look on this i believe uh travis
you squad you know what i'm saying
so in terms of hardware steam decks
about seven inch 1280x800 resolution
60hz lcd screen custom apu
all the rdd2 goodness and all that good
stuff like 16 gigs of ram
and then also besides that it looks like
um valve had three
models available so we had the 399 i
believe it comes with 64 gigs of
space uh and then we have the 529 model
which comes with 256 gigs of
nvme specifically a little extra custom
case and some stuff and then the big boy
649 512 gigabytes of nvme ssd
so this was hitting the interwebs it was
very
hot and heavy a lot to discuss here so
steam
deck let's start with our guest first
lord
travis man obviously i had the first
look what's your thoughts
on this thing yeah uh this is a
you know i think this is probably the
biggest scoop of the year hats off to
uh ryan mccaffrey uh doing this and
locking this in so
uh first my plug you should you should
follow ibm this month it is our ign
first uh so we have a bunch of stuff
coming later this month that we haven't
put out yet including an interview with
gabe newell
um we've got uh some more hands-on
impressions and
uh videos to show you as well so that'll
be coming out all
uh throughout this month which is really
exciting shout out to ryan on the uh 31
um questions that he had for the devs i
thought that was really informative
he really dug deep there but now that
you know obviously the team y'all got
the coverage like so
what about you where you at with this
device man
i'm excited i mean i pre-ordered one
right away um i love i mean
for me the booting up the the whole like
steam or booting up my my massive pc and
getting to steam and
uh downloading any updates that i need
and all that stuff is is the main thing
that keeps me away from my pc right i
play on xbox because it's just easy you
turn it on and
everything goes and you just you just
press play question
question so you go deeper pause um
which one did you pre-order yeah oh
obviously i pre-ordered the the most the
biggest one the fastest one
for me okay okay
continue continue yes
yeah i mean i i for me it's like it's a
work expense right like i have to invest
in these things i have to have all the
devices to be able to to try it out i'm
sure people are going to be
wondering you know if i review a game on
pc how did it work on steam deck right
now or did it work right yeah or did it
work because there's some games that
aren't going to work on it like i think
this week already some news broke that
destiny 2 probably won't play
on the steam deck at launch because it's
on an android device so
i'm sure they'll change that but but
there will be compatibility issues i'm
sure where like not every steam game is
going to work on this thing just because
what about this thing no one knows
yeah yeah well i mean they said it's a
pc so you could install microsoft on it
yeah and put in your
operating system well it will have a hit
to performance
of course because of uh the os of steam
is actually
more optimized for gaming what's running
on linux right
yeah it's like a linux version yeah it
is but it has it has a desktop you can
you can launch apps out of it just like
you would like a pc so
um even though it's running uh android i
think it
i think it probably will operate closer
to like a windows pc since that's what
uh steam users are kind of used to um so
yeah i'm really excited for this device
i think it could be a huge game changer
for people like me that
like pc but don't always like you know
uh crouching over a mouse and keyboard
yes uh like a like a beast
and uh yeah i i think it's i think it's
really awesome and i'm really excited to
see what tinkerers do with it because
i'm sure there's some like
secret use we don't know about where
they're gonna turn this into like a game
pass machine
or you know whatever it's gonna be cool
it's gonna be cool
we all know what's about to happen man
this thing's about to run switch games
better than switch games
let's not beat around the bush man this
is about to be the piracy's dream
that's exactly what it is oh for sure
for sure oh real quick we forgot uh
spacely sprockets with the ten dollar
canadian i believe
here's ten dollars to unlucky i unlocked
the ilp kung fu lipstick
messy i'm done he's messy sir now i know
what you're doing i know what you got
and then also put the crest up [ __ ] j
welcome
to rest
by the way with that particular one we
need nine more to do the next stream or
whatever it's going to be
now i'm going to do the morning we've
had six since we started
you know y'all know what you got to do
members or patreons and and we'll uh
we'll stream another game of your guys's
choice well
we're all going to pick one and we're
going to let you guys pick one of those
ones
no doubt no doubt actually there's a
super chat that just came in
for you i think it's at you
more than four years more yeah just keep
just keep going while i bring them all
up i know that okay
but i'll be actually gonna give it to
you but it's all good i'll give it to um
it was the king man so
where you at man steve deck is out here
you know what i mean i think me
oh um where are we at with this all
right so
um i i saw it and i was like
wait it's it's it's all about the stuff
that i love
opulence uh new tech you know always
want to be on the cutting edge of
whatever's happening
no i'm not doing any reviews i'm just in
the you know one of these little tech
heads that need to have every machine
that comes out
and you know i have every uh nvidia
shield
um and i like these little niche
consoles
or these little niche gaming experiences
that
isn't exactly made for everyone
it's made for particular tastes it's
like a boutique shop
and you know you you engage in these
things
in that manner i've seen all type of
weirdo memes like nintendo's dead
ford doesn't care what ferrari does
so you guys better respect exactly what
nintendo and i know you like nintendo is
ford
yes they are ford uh uh you know sony
is dodge and uh microsoft is chevy
i would actually i would actually argue
that
the steam deck has a lot more of an
uphill battle than
the switch does like the switch is is an
established handheld
product like this is coming out out of
nowhere and it's going to do well
because it has the support of steam
but at the end of the day it's like a
lot of the reasons people get these
handhelds is for the pokemons is
it they got a game that you know you
want to take over
now i'm not necessarily saying that no
one's going to want to take this on the
go
right but i'm saying the difference the
it's it's like when it comes to certain
things like this like
when newer games come out you're
probably going to want to play that on
your pc or consoles because you want to
play it at
the best fidelity you possibly can
something like this is going to be
really good for like indie space
because it's it's going to be the
ultimate machine see i'm thinking about
me and i'm not caring about
[Music]
i'm thinking about when i go to shows
and stuff like that
um i actually can take a real serious pc
with me
but as far as you know the individuals
feeling that nintendo oh this is this is
no i mean that's the little one that's
the ludu 500
shut up all right so that's not that's
nintendo operates in a space that is
not a prohibitive to you walking inside
the storm purchasing
plus the brand recognition like uh
addict was saying
uh carries a huge uh amount of cachet
so this switch oled the wide back which
i call it
because he's a wide body boy you know
that new uh
lean back machine so you know you know
you know you know
let me address this oh oh oh so so
let me just go ahead and read this we
got a two dollar super chat from gaming
forte oh
uh and as always hey king boo boo oh now
yeah yeah
we missed that sorry about that from
road run on not only even
i probably butchered your name addict
why did you beat the final boss in
chakra for smooth he told us in the
discord
look why is it every time kismu does
something you guys try to take it away
from him
it's like it's literally he'll he'll
have the victory and one of you people
want to put your
slobby ass hands in his mouth and snatch
that victory from
it's like that man beat that game let
him have that w they're not feeling that
yeah because that's that second it was
hard i haven't after that
that's what it is these people can't
beat the game
so they feel a themselves way that kid
smooth beat it and they want to they
want to do whatever they can to diminish
that that
that success yeah i don't know anyway
listen nintendo sony microsoft they all
have budget lines that they're working
in
and they know what is cost effective to
achieve this stuff
that is uh when you pull up to a light
and you have your ford and you look over
and you see the guy in a ferrari
right you don't see a bunch of ferraris
all over the place right you don't see
them
you know so as far as them selling they
don't care if they sell
it it's going to be a success for that
purchaser of that ferrari
yeah but y'all gonna forget about the
ferrari
as soon as the next ford f-150 is
announced
and that's going to be that switch pro
so when that switch pro actually
does come out easy analogy a ferrari and
a ford
like well because i know it's it's the
most
like a lambo or something a little bit
on the same level like
no it's not because it's it's it's it's
made for the masses
you understand nintendo is made for the
masses they don't really care about what
el what the hell is going on
the ford f-150 is the number one truck
being sold
so what is switch doing they're selling
the most units
yes the most unique out the door is
being sold by
nintendo they don't care about what
you're talking about they don't they
don't
give you because at the end of the day
like i think they're books
i think this is the best iteration of a
handheld we've seen
yeah but we can't actually get through
first yeah we can't act like they ain't
been like a hundred handhelds like
like trying to try to jump nintendo and
it always comes out in victoria
i mean nintendo been i mean i'm og king
remember like nintendo's been
beating superior handhelds from the game
black and white
yes with a black and white right i mean
remember when we had links they survived
game gear turbo express like nintendo
had survived
again and attic you made a good point
like you know we
people gotta relax you know what i'm
saying because at the end of the day
it's still those first party games
you know what the issue man everything
got to be a killer that's something else
yeah it's just like can't this thing
just be out and be an extension of your
steam library
like why you got to be a killer or
something you know what makes the switch
so good
it's got exclusive games to that
hardware right guess what
you can play everything on that handheld
honest on a pc
it's just like it's not one of those
things it's like look is a lot of people
going to want to go out and buy this
because
you could take a lot of your games
handheld yeah yes but they don't have
anything that's like i gotta have it for
that game well 600 650 dollars actually
changes the whole tone when you walk in
the store
period that's that right there changes
your my i don't care what anybody said
they could have said they was hyped up
for a lot of stuff
when it says buy now put this in your
basket
you're really starting to really think
tai already knows that okay this is a
business expense this is something i
have to do this is for my work and this
is where i'm going to go
push myself to the next level you don't
know about that
well i mean listen he's not going to let
it go past because this is work and
business opportunity
he already focused going in exactly what
you got to do maybe it's something that
you don't want to do
right if it was just you know for the
for your your thrills
but this is something that i have to do
i got to go this way and that's that's
it no i feel that when tommy goes inside
the store and tommy says to himself well
this is just for gaming
hmm that's that's when it becomes a hard
pill of swallow
now i'm just saying this because the
only reason why and i'm gonna get to
what
i personally wanted it why i personally
want
the the the big body boy um
that that ferrari robbie let's go um
i was going to go i was i was 10 seconds
from purchasing a steam machine
everybody remember those right oh yeah i
remember those
the great things about the steam machine
was they were modular and
you were able to upgrade and do all this
stuff and i love the controller
right how successful was that it wasn't
it wasn't successful at all it was
successful in theory but in execution it
failed miserably
they had it in places where you thought
it would sell but financially
the price point and the name recognition
did not sell and the fact that you had
different uh manufacturers actually
muddied the waters well you would think
it's a good thing it wasn't it was an
actual bad thing
consumers like to go to one thing and
they like to know that their stuff is
being manufactured
by this people not knowing that really
you know there's like four different
playstations being manufactured
at different spots in the world they
don't know that but they they feel safe
than that brand
right this brand was too open so
right before i'm about to buy it that's
when it fell out
it lost that steam basically okay but
the controller was perfect the
controller on this
mimics the same aspects and the best
qualities
of that same controller that's where
my intrigue goes because when i play my
switch
first it's too small for my large
ridiculous man-sized giant
baby hands um and
not to mention king just to interrupt
you real quick it looks like the weird
placement like i'm gonna have to have
like thumb surgery yeah
yeah it's kinda i gotta see how it's
like i gotta like play like claw stuff
but
it is better than doing this playing uh
your switch with
you know catching cramps in between i i
don't know i don't have an issue playing
my switch like that i do
but i mean that that's cool
literally you just said a minute ago you
didn't care about anyone else's opinion
i play the switch just fine like maybe
your hands a little bit bigger than mine
but
i know my hands are pretty big man but
exactly see i don't care if it doesn't
hurt you but it doesn't
hurt me that's why there's a lot of
world going on i brought a pro
controller for this so
um it looked like it was comfortable i
saw all the accessible buttons
that were there at the track pad type of
feel to it
i it that part intrigued me now
the biggest thing that i respect was the
ssd
that is the biggest jump guys uh from
last generation
to current generation yeah is the ssd
the uniformity in that one aspect
changes how we interact now
pc's been doing this pc's been waiting
for the uniform
the base model the base model doesn't
have no no no no
and a lot
i'm trying to explain to you how
important it is i'm listening
kids all right thank you thank you for
your
your your interruption it's crazy
yeah i love i love it um but at the same
time the ssd is the most important
aspect of this because really puts it in
line thank you
it puts it in line with current consoles
what does it put it in line with
with everything that's happening in the
world right now the speed
okay okay the fact that you you logging
in
very quickly ty said that he doesn't
like to go to his pc sometimes because
he got it
oh travis sorry yeah sorry sir
and i'm like it's so dapper it's the
fact that
you know yeah i threw it all off now my
bad
my bad
anyway i'll jump in real quick oh thank
you yes the ssd
obviously i i i hear what you go oh look
you know it's
it's interesting for me you know it's
one of those things that you know
obviously i'm a techie i like i like
power i like advancements you know what
i'm saying i think
the funny thing about this is the timing
it's not that
i think a lot of people yes everybody go
to compare and say oh it's the oled kill
and all that it's just that
when the old switch oled was announced
this was kind of the jump people were
hoping for
from nintendo so when they come out and
they like yo
it's the same just oled you know what
i'm saying in a little bit of screen in
the wide back as king says
you know what i'm saying like for people
they were like oh that's all we doing
you know what i'm saying so then this
comes out
and i know i feel valve had to be a
little nervous prior to the switch
oled announcement travis just because
like yo what if they
do something that's really going to
match us and they got the first party
you know we could be in trouble here so
i think they probably breathed a sign of
relief like oh it's the same old smith
you know with no bluetooth or whatever
so for me
it's everything i wanted the switch oled
to do that for me can i interrupt yes
please
simpson you know me i just i just want
to say one thing
yes they capitalized off a misstep
yes they did a sony move they saw
what the internet said and it was like
yo yo yo yo
you got that ready to roll we got that
yeah the real
just put it out i don't care yes now put
it out now
because the world wants this now and i'm
gonna have to disagree with you okay
that's nice um
again switch through it out on a
thursday
right and the reason why i switched
through that information out on thursday
that's when you lukewarm with your
messenger right because you know
friday's for bad news
yes right so thursday if it's good
all right cool if it's bad we got the
weekend and wash that away
you know they just gonna eat that
nintendo knew
nintendo knew that you guys wanted
something else and they said but you
gonna get this
i think the thing is though i don't
necessarily think nintendo cares what we
don't like nintendo knows
the power that's required to make the
type of games that they want to make
and i've always been very very firm with
the belief that nintendo sabotage has
its own power
because they don't care about third
party it's like they'll like it's like
look
like obviously they want that 30 they
get from these third parties no they
can't
during that party though because they
wouldn't have changed their philosophy
at the start of the switch
well you see the thing is they're being
more accepting
i think than past generations but at the
end of the day they don't care if it's
on there or not it's just these
other third parties i disagree with that
okay can i finish my statement continue
to your ips is high but i do one night
yes
but we're gonna let him go these other
third party they're the ones wanting
stuff on switch because there's such an
install base on yes they're the ones
going to
to second-party developers that are
specialized in making games for the
switch because they want their games on
switch
nintendo don't care if they're not on
there or not because at the end of the
day
all that does is give them competition
like there's a reason
like i've always stated like how much
you think god award would self it was
only first party playstation games on
for god
on playstation it would probably double
to triple its numbers
and that's what you always have seen on
nintendo you know their games do very
very well
because of the departures they have and
the games that they have that's really
the only things that's on the switch
like
right now if you look on skyward store
are you going to see anything else
really that's out beside skyward sword
no so what do you think people are going
to buy that's on the switch
they're going to buy skyward sword
there's there's no big third party stuff
coming out this
this holiday a lot of games that come
out
literally yeah
so we don't have competition within
ourselves
so we can uh dominate our own platform
you've seen it happen over and over
again the games come
the games come out six months to a year
after they come out on other platforms
you see true not all the time about
hades yeah
party game of the year i i i'm not re
i'm referring to the juggernauts that
come out of there
yeah so so you we should parse what
we're talking about then but nintendo
doesn't care about
a certain type of third party right they
don't care about third party that's like
going for 4k graphics call of duty and
you're releasing that
but they do care about third party and
they're they're caring about third party
in a way
that i think the other platforms are
missing because nintendo gets games
like hades like uh you know some of
those indies and
my girl yeah i get them exclusively or
first and you know my girlfriend plays
like dating sims and like the switches
the the exclusive platform to do that
unless you're diving deep into steam
um so i think that i i think ninten i
think you're right addict that nintendo
doesn't care i mean we're talking about
people that released the 3ds when
everybody was saying all mobile devices
were gonna die because we were on our
phones
and now we're in this reverse golden age
where we've got uh
you know the switch oled model coming
out and the steam
uh getting its own platform and and
microsoft is doing game pass and saying
you can
on any device it's ridiculous but what i
was referring to travis is like
we get in october november when the
battlefields the call of duties and
the the dying light twos drop nintendo
in their little ivy tower is like we'll
drop it in november they're like all
these games coming over
they ain't on our platform like and
that's what i've always felt like i've
always felt like they they care to third
parties but if it's something
that they don't they never pursue it
it's just like it's if it's something
that
that comes to them and they'll go to
stuff like you know hades that's
different because
that's something that works for them but
i'm referring to the ubisoft games to
the ea
game i understand when those type of
games come out they're like look like
you're going to have to meet us not the
other way around i think
i think both of you are right um in
theories because
i believe what attic is saying in theory
that you know nintendo doesn't care
for you know the call of duty's and
stuff like that because they actually
have exclusive content that bring people
and the sales figures dictate that
but i also feel like you know uh travis
is right
because the fact of the matter is
nintendo is killing it with these indies
and getting these
niche star games that that they turn
into stars they really good gameplay
games
games that actually find a home and
games that actually push the platform
forward which is third party which we're
seeing
this is the first time really
third-party games in a long time on a
nintendo platform
has actually thrived so uh i i think
actually
both of you guys are right in in in the
theories
and you know just addicts sees uh the
stuff that he really cares about yeah
and i think you know travis sees the
stuff that he's really to me king is
if they care truly cared about these big
30-part party stuff
i don't think this oled stuff would be
an upgrade but they don't they don't you
know
i don't think they care about that
because they're chasing a different type
of yeah
there's wisdom in nintendo's strategy
they're saying like
you know this isn't a zero-sum game we
don't all have to try to do the same
thing and compete for the same people
and they're not and
every single time they do that they've
had like a hit on their hands
it's really only when they try to
compete in that space with like the wii
u and they go
oh we've got mass effect 3 and you can
play it in 720p that everybody's like
the same the same
yeah that's what i was saying travis i
would say not necessarily stuff like
hades
i was saying when nintendo designs a
system they only look for what they want
to build they don't look for what other
people want to build and once the
system's out
then they'll go out and get stuff that
can realistically run on their platform
and they can do
well on their platform but as far as
like call of duty they don't care if
that's on a system
can i address the the yeah i just wanted
to know
if if i'm able to address the the
thoughts of microsoft uh
being this is microsoft's little steam
machine let me get my balls
i agree with the triple
a graphical showcase games
yeah they don't necessarily care about
that because that's that doesn't fit
their profile
however i don't think those games are
the majority and i still think there's a
ton
of indies and a ton of other third-party
games that maybe double a
that they have worked with developers to
port to the platform
how many times have we said yo i can't
believe they got mortal kombat on switch
yo i can't believe nba 2k is on switch
you don't say like let's kill them
exactly so at the end of the day they've
changed their strategy
from the starter switch and that's a big
reason why i actually
bought a switch because i'm one of those
guys i'm not like attic i don't
necessarily care for their first party
like that
at all like besides zelda you know what
i'm saying yeah
i'm not the mario guy and all the other
mario iterations i don't really go crazy
for that that's not for me
but then when i hear okay wow they have
all these third parties and then these
indies
are coming exclusively to switch that's
a big deal where people
where developers are fighting over the
eshop space
and just to get to be seen that's a big
deal that's a philosophy change and the
last thing i'll say about it is that
the reason why i knew they were serious
is when developers with them and nvidia
working with the api and the tools to
give to devs and say hey
we could scale that down with unreal
like using tools that they knew ahead of
time
could work to be scalable to even think
about the switch but another bus switch
look at that one more thought about this
stop
which is that i actually think that
steam is chasing nintendo on this one i
don't think they're competing for the
same type of gamer but i think
steam is always on their back foot
whenever they're
doing hardware because they've they've
tried to do this before and they
haven't really had a lot of success
they're great at platform they're great
at software when they release games
it takes forever but when they do it
it's great but their hardware
aside from the valve index their vr
headset
it's it's just the history is just a ton
of like failures and like stuff not
working out so i think
they're they're making a bold move it's
it's big but there's a lot of questions
how do you play a steam game if there's
20 buttons it's like an mmo or you have
like a hot bar how do you play that on
the
the stick deck you know there's there's
lots of questions that they need to
answer that i think uh
where there's going to be a lot of
compatibility issues and if this thing
can't run
everyone's game then it's going to be
like all right well what games can it
run is there a list somewhere you know
all this all these questions that people
are going to have
uh what add-ons do you have to create
i'm sure for some of the games you're
going to just have to plug in a keyboard
and mouse since that's something you can
do
on the steam deck and play it on on uh
on a monitor essentially which which in
that case why don't you just buy it
yeah yeah so i think there i think it is
an uphill battle i think it's going to
sell like hotcakes but it will
it will live or die by uh its ability to
actually keep players there and like
serve
its purpose so i'm interested to see how
it works but i think
i think uh the advantage is certainly to
nintendo like they know how to do this
that's right and they have the player
i don't think it's going to be
successful i think it's going to come
out the gate really good
and then it's just going to further down
like because i i think it's going to
have that hype coming out the gate and
then you know people go this is good
this is cool it's like but we'll be
playing on it exactly
it's going to be that curiosity that we
talk about remember
that scene uh when i told people the
steam machine is like oh oh yeah
yeah they had a whole sectioning and
gamestop
there's a whole section controller was
the biggest draw
you know to it and this thing um
it's going to work for certain
individuals
like for that for the college student um
because remember this is a full-fledged
pc
yeah you know this is yeah this is a
full-fledged pc so you can actually do
your work and stuff like that on it
um and this changes how you view it if
you
if you take it away from the gaming
space the possibilities for it is
immense
if you only isolate it to the gaming
space that's where
failures will lie that's my opinion of
it because
people keep looking at the abundance and
games
and the steam library and all the stuff
that you can do
but at the same time when you're looking
at the abundance you know travis also
brought up the same part where
what happens to the limitations what can
i not play
imagine your favorite game that you
wanted to take this on the go
doesn't play it which which has come out
with destiny right that happened to cog
yeah that happened with that because
they literally said that proton whatever
the steam os that they're using
is not compatible with destiny 2 because
destiny has
um anti-cheat that's a conflict so
five had to put out a statement saying
that um you know they're gonna be
working with partners and stuff but no
these are valid concerns i'm not i'm not
yeah no it's a terrible concern because
also then you go space wise space wise
if you go for the smaller one the
smaller one is what it
what is that uh 64.
you can't even load in the master chief
collection
so what are you doing like okay so the
real
call of duty drop you can't even put in
call of duty
so well they can if you use the ssd slot
i guess
if you guys are too big i mean
but we're talking about let's just talk
about what you have
right right what you walking the door
with on the smaller version
enough for you yeah you know you're kind
of limited i think
in that space yeah
forget about it then i think the the
best case scenario we can have
i hope it's successful you know i hope
it's successful because i want them to
turn
uh to turn nintendo straight around be
like yo
okay okay maybe we need to do some
updates all right we need to get a
better online infrastructure they're
killing us there but
like your own logic nintendo don't care
well they don't care now
but if this comes out and it's a massive
success and it's taking away from their
little pie then they'll start to care
but you know it remains to be seen we
don't know the future
right right and it could come out be mad
successful or it could come out
and do well for a couple weeks and just
die off but we don't know until it comes
out
so like like i'm saying like i mean all
valid points um
yeah for me like i said it was something
very interesting i love the tech in it
you know as far as the rda2
obviously the vr vrs you know what i'm
saying raytracing so
three of us here is buying it right yeah
exactly three months yeah
which goes behind it so um two of them
had two of you
wow you gonna talk about that i i have
to have my tinker unit
oh wow i might have to send mine to you
yeah savage but yeah now for me it's
very compelling i think
it's a new space for them you know
obviously yeah you know
yeah it's a it's portable but it's a pc
you know what i'm saying and that part
is intriguing you know i i like the fact
that
things that i've clamored for nintendo
to do like
bluetooth you know let's say yeah you
know what i'm saying
you know an nvme hard drive that's very
exciting to me proper party chat
had been able to use devices i thought
the um a party chat yeah yeah yeah
come on and then like i obviously you
know i don't know how i feel about
the analog placement but i do like the
fact they have those track pads
to simulate mouse yes you know movement
that's a big deal you know
it's because a lot obviously a lot of pc
games require a mouse and i don't i
don't think everybody's gonna want to
connect an official
keyboard and mouse all the time for that
like i said you do a pc so i like that
little flavor there and um yeah the key
is going to be like i said it's linux
based
you know i want to make sure the battery
light is two to eight
the same thing like switch switch
battery and all that either now let's
come on now
but at the end of the day what i like
about it is the options
you got steemo west it's up to steam to
in them to say hey we're going to work
with partners to be competitive it's up
to them
but if they don't you can put windows on
this bad boy
see what's my thing i want to make it
the game pass
pc device right so my thing is i put
that windows 11 up on there
throw that game pass p and playing games
locally
at that is very very appealing so
it's up it up they got to work with the
tools they got to work with the
scalability it's it's all on them
for this thing to for them to go hard to
try to make it a success but i will
i was surprised to see how much
overwhelming
positive kind of feedback they would get
they were trending on twitter obviously
yeah how much positive things they would
get because it to me it felt like a me
techie device and i didn't know if
everybody was caught and everybody was
like yeah you're kind of shuttling it
yeah i don't know you'll have to worry
about anything in terms of like game
pass i don't think you'll have to
download windows
yeah i think microsoft's probably on the
back end working with them for a good
success lap that's what i was going to
say i think yeah i think
you can buy game pass on steam and not
to mention you know
our super chat earlier which we'll get
to those here in a minute yeah
you know he asked like what is our
thoughts about you know them working as
this is
their uh they're dedicated like handheld
for game pass
i think that's exactly what that's what
i think that's what i'm going to see
to me the way i look at it that's why i
think they got a shot
is because microsoft and steam have been
playing nice
finally recently this generation right
we're seeing
microsoft games my microsoft should be
stubborn you got to go to our our
microsoft store to get our stuff you
could only get it
at the game pass pc at that's over now
now
you're seeing the sea of thieves the
flights simulate all these first party
games
now on steam and people are buying them
and they have a success there
so to me it only makes sense especially
microsoft who've kind of dipped their
toe they never
really officially made a handheld even
though the xbox community wants them
you could literally say hey that's the
handheld device
we make that compatible and scalable
with the with the os that they're using
put that game pass app or whatever and
really now
start to jump off on market penetration
with game pass which is what they want
they want those game pass up so if this
thing takes off it's to microsoft's
advantage to play nice
with valve let valve do all the heavy
lifting of hardware and just throw that
bad boy on there
at the end of the day how many people
are willing to spend 400 dollars to have
access to game fest that's not an xbox
i don't know if it'll even be necessary
just because xcloud i mean
at some point there will be close to
parity in certain parts of the world so
it'll be
more uh yeah what you want because i'm
sure
on xcloud you'll be playing an above
720p on your phone
yeah versus a 400 device where maybe you
don't have lag issues that you might
have
on xcloud but you're playing at a lower
resolution and you actually have to pay
like upfront cost for it is that is that
the lord of clarity
in the back door coming through uh can
you hear me oh very small
very smoothly
i'm in a dungeon but i brought my
equipment but my my idiot self
left my uh my power supply oh so you're
limited
i'm on borrowed time and then i went
looking around and and nobody
everybody here has baby laptops so
there's no power supplies
let you get your balls off get your
balls off sir about the steam deck
um yeah got my hands on one we'll see uh
mine is set to ship
on second quarter 2022 yeah oh you the
q2 dude like me
yeah i like you too oh shout out to the
horrible
pre-ordering processor do you know
anyone that's in the queue
like that's in the tournament i know you
want one look at that look at this
is 20 21 for yours i mean they're
shipping in december so december
wow so everyone's getting it
one is the earliest oh okay continues up
so
uh yeah excited about it um i think the
the most exciting thing about it is
really is that 400
price point because it makes it
interesting on a lot of levels that's
really the only
you know when you you start thinking
about a 350 dollar switch oled
obviously you know nintendo has their
first parties there so that's where
you know why people are going to that
platform but uh
i mean you know i'm neither going to
confirm or deny that i have a version of
you know
there's a breath of the wild version
somewhere in my house
so um but i just think it's exciting
because it's an open platform
and at this point now you could you know
it you know you can turn that into a
game pass box as well
and there's a lot of things you could do
i intend to do that as well because i
you know steam os is not my friend um
i'd rather just uh
install windows but i'm excited about it
so paris said xbox game pass app will be
on the stream deck for cloud streaming
right and you have the option to buy
games on steam for native play
like to me i get that and i think that
will be an option here but it's just
like
at that point a lot of people have mad
expensive phones so why would someone go
out and spend
four hundred dollars on a handheld when
i know if microsoft positions it shout
out the power if microsoft positions it
as an x-cloud device i ain't necessarily
feel that
because my dig is when i would have
played all the gold there will be no
network to access
so i want to use it that's the advantage
of the switch
the advantage of the switch is located
subway train plane
you know what i'm saying so now that's
why to me
if that's the case windows 11 will be on
this bad boy
with the quickness because i'm wiping
that os if they don't play nice i want
to play
local that that's about to me that's
such a cool advantage
to have those local and and to get xbox
into space but sorry so i just i just
had to get there no i i
you're right i i think for me you know
xcloud being something that's really
viable for everyone is still
years away i think you know some people
have great connections some people don't
um so for me it's always about local
player you guys will remember a couple
of years ago i was like i want microsoft
to make a handheld
and you guys like nah cloud xcloud cloud
they have xbox
you know but the thing about it is
nothing compares to
the local experience nothing ever will
for sure so
with a machine this powerful you know
when you think about the the sort of the
arc of
of technology everything gets more
powerful and small and smaller
and that's where we're going so you know
for me
this is this is amazing and to me i want
to
see how they market it to the mass
market even if they even care to market
it's the math that's a good question
that's a good question because that 400
price point puts it right there in line
with that switch and obviously
they don't have the switch first party
games but they have steam
so i wonder if that's even a thing for
him but i i saw this interview with the
the ign interview with gabe newell and
he was adamant about we had to reset
four hundred dollar fee
that yeah exactly the home travis whole
time i'll see you i'm just
adamant about that 400 price point
so i think they have big plans for this
like
across the board right um to be able to
touch gamers that
have never looked at steam and the pc
ecosystem so it's
it's very interesting here's where i see
it
in two years from now i see this is like
a piracy's dream
i see for the most part the casual
audience they're not buying it because
like
obviously for for a couple hundred
dollars more you buy a pc obviously
you know people are gonna buy for that
uh for that remote
yeah that's another thing good little
man for the amount of money that you're
going to spend on this
you can you can that's what i'm saying
like the whole thing
this conversation is mute for the amount
of money that you're spending on this
you could buy a little man and you could
get one of those things that you put on
top of it tonight yeah
for maybe 100 don't fail i got to be in
on both
google i will let y'all battle out for
portable supremacy and i'm bit i'm
getting that x screen
shout out to them i mean one of the one
of them is really not that portable
little little man
you can put millimeters out of the
backpack i'm not looking out little man
on the bus
class food trade and my series that
little bag will be there with the
everybody gonna be looking at me and
[Music]
you know it's like i said like it's like
i hope i hope i'm wrong i hope this
comes out mad successful because
until there's someone there that can
compete with nintendo on the handheld
marketing plus
they're we're going to continuously get
this you know what you know what you
don't but you know what
[Laughter]
dating a different market nintendo is a
more
younger yeah
said they don't care about any of this
stuff they talk about
they're gonna be continuing to do it
after that no all they did was give you
skyward swords
i would be willing i would be willing to
bet that the average nintendo switch
player doesn't even know it's
doesn't even know what it is i'm not
saying that i'm saying that
for you know there's a lot of cogs out
there you know
nintendo might not necessarily care if
you buy their console or not
but they know that that money you know
they'll see that money slowly slip away
if the console is successful
if the handheld is successful you know
you'll see stuff like that happen but
it's like i said a couple weeks ago i'm
willing to bet you the majority
you know nintendo doesn't try to sell to
the cogs the premium experience they try
to sell to the family of five or five
about to have a switch i have multiple
switches now it's gonna be
a bunch of us uh pirates are
that's that's that's all we are ah
sitting here with a dead machine
i'm pulling for steve you're gonna have
a hot two years this is a hot dog
hold on hold on you didn't get it king
you didn't try to get one yeah yeah he's
getting okay
she got one i'm listening i'm laughing
travis talking about he's in cute what
i'm like word
so let's say you do emulate switch games
onto this thing
can they make private lobbies for like
online games or
or is it is that really hard to do with
that you can probably
do whatever yeah i don't know why would
you ask me
you seem very well versed at the subject
so
i see people in the chat saying they're
going to emulate the switch and you know
a lot of people are going to do this but
to me
what sells the switch a lot is is the
mario karts it's the super smash
brothers like
if you can't play online with those
games i feel like it's going to take me
to go again
switch online is so robust yeah it's not
a bus but people still play all
this [ __ ]
on the pc platform yes you can get all
of the things that you want from
nintendo that they won't give you
the pc platform
and the other thing i will say before we
move over we got to get the super chat
because the super chat's on fire for
this topic
is when you when they spoke to the dead
shout out to ryan
he spoke to the devs and they said what
surprised me
is they are giving the tools to develop
the actual console to other
manufacturers
so you can make your own steam deck if
you want to have the whatever
bigger or different
you know what this is this is a giant
conspiracy to take down nintendo
they're like one of these is bound to
work if if
if they joint don't hit they might give
it to somebody that could make the
perfect model
look like we're taking on a colossal
it's like but you know what we're going
to do
we're going to shadow blood
since the days of the sears atari 2600
in fact we know that this does not work
you was like yo what's up with that
that especially with your people nexus
making these ports your heart pc
gaming is on the rise and this is a
space they've never been
there until they open up their boxes and
tell me what pcs they played all trust
them they could be playing all those old
cool type of screens
this is way back just showing support to
the realm phil
to gab game pass right that's what i got
we're gonna let's see what else what
else we got so many i i'll get uh
look like i got to percolate oh damn it
jump me crazy i was just about to get
the percolator he was in there
that's all i have uh okay so
i have uh you you got the good afternoon
the percolator 9000
oh right i only want something oh i
missed mad people though
i'm reading i'm ready good afternoon
lords before that i miss people
uh i write all those just showing
support to the realm field to
gab game pass right raid and blaze did
we get dragon boy yo beat it or
something i think i missed him
i'm way back like okay i'm reading like
they've super chatted multiple times
okay
previous ones then we got um
road runner uh again with uh did did you
uh
he did everything but the final boss on
stream a little fishy
once again if you if you have an issue
with kids smooth
and succeeding and challenges well he
actually failed that challenge but we're
not going to go into that
go talk to him he does planet xbox every
sunday
every wednesday
move who is not there to defend himself
so you know like okay it's like going
into the woods and shooting a gun talk
about i got him
nobody knows it just kills me like
he beats a game because they can't beat
it i beat it for him
whatever we're going to keep move on
we got a a 25 super chat from acepedia
i'd definitely butcher that
uh solutions to the uh to the lords of
my condolences to lord attic i just got
news recently i hope you're doing well
sir
have a good one and god bless i
appreciate it man we have a two dollar
superchat from brat
salute lord stream deck let's go why you
gotta be disgusting
look i i gotta start being extra cause
he's all i gotta start seeing what's
inside his pc pulls
now you're gonna have to start opening
up and then i gotta start verifying
what's in there
running on a wheel i know right here
we got a five dollar super chat from
raiden blade and attempted to fill
yeah we laugh you out of japan you
instead in braining game pass to switch
we heard that you and gabe had a chat so
he's pretty much saying instead of them
doing the game pass thing
are they still gonna do that watch what
happens we got a five super chat from uh
raiden blade gabe loves
xbox it can only become successful if
they team up with game pass just saying
i will say that that is one of the key
components that might not this be
mine will get in punk i'm telling you
man we got a 10
super jack from dragon heart uh shout
out to the um
to the iron lords aka the dif uh the
deities of gaining
your shout out to glor cognito aka mr
breaky
damn neck
video you was rocking out make sure to
keep that neck
you can upgrade an ssd and most people
will buy the larger
uh handset it's the only competitor to
nintendo remember the japanese market
loves pc gaming
we got a two dollar strip trap from
raiden blade lord solved the new barry
white hello ladies
yeah he was extra small when he pulled
up whatever you got a five dollar
subtract from slo-mo backslash
uh-oh i don't care what y'all say we
emulating nintendo games baby
first party games xbox first party games
and better
running nintendo games i will say games
like zelda and stuff they're gonna run
silky smooth on this play oh yeah for
sure for sure for sure then we got a
two dollar super chat from silk slayer
pro tip retro art is on steam
we got a five dollar super chat from
bret briggerham uh
crazy prediction switch pro is xbox
series n nintendo he's talking about oh
my gosh
the switch was a gift me what about the
one behind sarah bond
phil oh interesting we got a five
superchat from
okataku nintendo never had
and will never lose the handheld market
there yeah they've won everyone their
home consoles fell so they made their
hand held into a console and it boomed
mm-hmm interesting we all caught up sir
no we got one more
yeah we got a bunch we got the last let
me read this
we got the last emperor five dollar
super chat why can't i download xcloud
games to icloud
that's another is how the force works
it's not how it works
[Applause]
what's going on baby what's going on
hold on we got hip-hop
this is crazy this is crazy continue
we're going to switch we got hit five
though hold up
little man plus the x screen giving me
80s apple two vibes
somebody get me that oregon trail on the
floppy disk
all get dysentery together okay
michael aka best size finest five dollar
super chat first stars uh
first off our r.i.p the biz yeah
bismarck yeah our peter biz man
for real salute always absolutely
absolutely
uh now back to business playstation is
tragical
oh my god
i'm not doing that we're not doing that
we're doing
that
take care much love to you and your
family no doubt no doubt so we are all
cut up we got the
legendary hot dog seven
logitech g d o g who's been
putting it down brooklyn stand up what
is going
on hip hop talk to me brother how you
doing
hip-hop gamer no stranger to danger
number one journalist quickly i changed
the game
to the building he's good yo yo listen
first this is how we gonna set it off
son go let's go first off
at it i know i'm not in front of you but
i'm giving you a big hug right now bro
i love you bro i mean that man i'm so
sorry
trust me everybody that know i've been
through that you know what i'm saying my
grandma so i get it
but i love you and you know you are very
well supported
so all the blessings to you man your
family man rp
so i want to show you love one thing i
can say about hip-hop man is
you know this dude has always been mad
supportive of iop since the start since
we had 20 people in the chat
probably less than that man hip hop and
his friends were probably fine with the
people
the only man who stops an interview
every event
always gives us love i remember one of
the events like he was doing an
interview
yeah and he controlled them yeah
and what's funny is he like we had a
right someone was us with us and he just
grabbed them and took them back to the
control people
every time i get a chance you have to
check it see what you're doing you don't
say you're always moving always ahead of
the game
but we got it we got a good topic
this is a very spicy topic i am glad you
are here
cause this one it kind of jumped off the
respect for peachy
wait what's up what's up with bg oh i
need to pull up oh
i never see total is that the legendary
lord of
weapon will himself is that is that
yes yes it is
oh yo you know so crazy i didn't even
see him i even see him
the infamous legendary lord himself
super statues in the building giving up
are you down with the king
baby i see the reference y'all
but look we gotta get to it this is a
fun one y'all a lot of passions like
this one
so look let's get it all the timeline
seems to start
with all double fines so shout out to
them um psychonauts 2 coming soon you
know what i'm saying everybody's getting
excited
and then they brought out an option to
bring out our invincibility mold
in the game you know what i'm saying so
that kind of went out there and then i
believe xbox the xbox account tweeted
say hey
you know whatever way you finish the
game is it's fine you know they support
that
they put that out there and then um
things went left a little bit
so i think shout out to again lord kyle
and good friend to the realm he had put
this out and um
i think this is what started the debate
because prior to that
i don't know the lady's name but i guess
she's a journalist and she had put out
in response to the xbox tweet
about um beating the game on the lowest
difficulty it still beat the game
she put out she never played a game for
review on anything
but the easiest difficulty so then that
sparked
a collin response and then he pretty
much was like hey if you can't or won't
beat games or anything
harder than easy and you're reviewing
them
from that perspective and not from that
perspective of the average player
then your criticism is worthless seek
out critics who actually like games
it's all getting a little trite and then
a little bit of smoke happened the
accessibility community came
in and also then carla then responded
and he say
um he said basically saying to um
to say to some say worthless is too hard
a word i agree he said let me phrase it
like this
if you're reviewing games on easy then
you're not playing the game as intended
game criticism is aimed at a core
audience
not casual and then he pretty much said
that he had no issue with the
accessibility
committee so this has been going back
and forth twitter's on fire right now
everybody wants to talk about the easy
difficulty reviewing game thing
i got to set it off with hip-hop first i
don't know how your time is so i want to
get you in
um hip-hop i
so how you feel about this whole thing
man i know i know your history with
certain things but i want to know how
you feeling on this subject
you know what well me i'm transparent
everybody know like you know i play
games i use
cheat codes i do like i don't care i
play the way i want to play
so here's the thing i want to speak
towards uh
uh colin right so i don't interview
so many developers over like my time
uh you know experience and stuff like
that right and
when he talks about the way a game was
intended to be played
right my question would be is um what
facts do you have to say that um this uh
developer intended you to play it
like this way because and uh here's why
i asked that question right
let's say you're the owner of a like
y'all have iron lord shirts right
right and you and y'all sell these
shirts you know people can purchase
y'all merch
so if i buy a shirt right and let's say
it's short let's say it's a long sleeve
shirt
and i'm like you know what i'm gonna cut
the sleeve so i'm gonna do something
different with it i'll add my own little
flavor to it right
like that does that matter y'all made
the sale
i want to experience the shirt and
support the way i want to support
done deal so when people say the
intention right
what is the proof of the intention
because every developer that i've ever
spoke to right and did interviews with
their goal is that people have fun
playing their game
right that's it well i guess to your
question the only thing i did see from
him was that
he said with playstation the way the
trophies are allocated
that they could tell by i guess the
majority who are playing on normal or
whatever the default is that i think
it's one of the reference to use but but
my question
i want to go back to you for a second
like my question i get where you're
going
with you play the game how you won't
play the game right yeah that is you're
right you do what you want to do i guess
my question specifically is how do you
feel
about reviewers reviewing the game
on easy and maybe i don't know maybe
sometimes
they're not saying it or just reviewing
the game on easy like
where are you at okay i got you i got
you okay so then you got to ask yourself
what is the merits of how you're
reviewing this game okay so if i
so if i play ratchet and clank right if
i play it on easy
that don't change the graphical
experience that i'm having okay
and i'm rating the game based on
graphics too if i if if i'm
uh doing sound my easy or hard
or whatever difficulty doesn't change
the sound or change the fun that i'm
having if i'm having bad frame rates
and stuff like that well i'm playing on
easy or hard if i'm having bad frame
rates
it's gonna happen no matter what level i
play it on okay so based on the merits
of how i'm reviewing a game in the
categories that's there
the easy normal or difficulty that stuff
don't matter now here's what i would say
as an
exception to the rules so to speak
because i know people would say this
right
so if you let's say you play a game on
normal right right
and they they come at you uh let's say
certain enemies attack you
a certain way oh my god this is a crazy
podcast right now how are you doing
this is crazy let's get it let's get it
finished let's go let's go all right let
me finish up now let's say you're
playing a game
on um on hard difficulty yes and stuff
like that right
and let's say the enemies commit to more
aggressively and stuff like that
okay cool it's a tougher challenge
and if you want that tougher challenge
that's fine or if you want an easier
challenge that's fine however you play
is how you play but the way you review a
game the elements of how you review a
game
doesn't um affect the difficulty that
you uh play it at
challenges challenge i last example down
give somebody else
if somebody let's say i'm playing uh it
could be call of duty
and then i'm playing on the hardest
level if they shoot me one or two times
i die so it's a harder challenge right
right and then if i play it on easy
they do the exact same thing but instead
of two shots it'll probably take like
eight shots the nine shots okay
to kill me um as i move forward either
way i'm still experiencing the game and
as long as you experience the game
and you review it based on those
categories okay regardless
regardless of difficulty that don't
matter let me ask you one like and i'll
pass it off because you're making some
some interesting points
my question to you is again you you're
cool with that with the viewer
should the reviewer be
okay is it okay if the reviewer does not
put the difficulty that he reviewed the
game in his review no you should no no
no no
you should you got to be transparent if
you're not transparent that's messed up
okay as a reviewer you got to be
transparent if you ain't transparent
then you're not being authentic to your
audience so that's not fair no no
look let me tell you the whole scenario
i played cuphead
with cheating
i got my game genie i got my trainers
all of that i played away i went play i
played the lion king when i was a kid
that jordan got on my nerves put the
game genie in smoke
have existed for years i mean you go
back to
contra up up down left right you already
know
chicos is a part of the culture so
anybody that tries to
deny that it's their own way of trying
to feel good about themselves
are you a flying gamer crap that's what
we're doing you know what's funny
hip-hop
anyone who said they didn't use cheat
codes asked them if they used chicos at
gta
vice city gta yeah especially when that
helicopter level let's get it popped
so anyway so i got the yeah so the final
thing with cuphead i played cuphead
right so
a lot of people were saying what they
were saying so like a word well battle
me
battle me and we'll see where a real
hard difficulty is
and shout out to my boy king but you
know what happened oh
good then you went for
let them stick around for the whole show
and i'm looking at it and i just took a
snack i'm ready
okay hold on we got
i gotta get paris i gotta get bg let's
get make sure paris's levels are good
lord paris gamertag radio
what is going on kind of funny xcast
what's up oh what what's good yeah yeah
okay beautiful levels are beautiful so
look easy game difficulty reviews this
is a hot one in the topic
you know i know this is going back and
forth you know what's your feeling on
this whole thing sir
no it's funny shout out to hip-hop as
soon as i saw hip-hop coming here i was
like yo i got to come up here
i i think he laid it out pretty well
just overall i mean it really just comes
down to this as far as reviewers go
disclose it that's simple i agree i
think there is definitely
a perspective that should be there for
people that are playing on
uneasy mode because we talk about people
with disabilities accessibility all of
that
that crowd wants to know what it's like
to play a game on easy is it worth their
time to to go play so absolutely
i think there's there definitely should
be easy
mode reviews out there just the person
reviewing it needs to say hey i played
this on easy mode i played it on normal
legendary whatever the case so the
reading it consuming that
can form an opinion around that is this
game worth my time
right um look colin and i have our
history yeah
that doesn't even matter he shouldn't
say what he said when he said it
he did clarify it he did clarify which
was which was good
but i don't think it's fair to go after
her like that
because she played a game on easy that's
the way that she played it now did she
disclose that i don't know but she
obviously openly
talked about i play i review games on on
easy mode
right if that review isn't for you go
find a review that is
that's really making this such an issue
that's what i don't understand okay so
yeah
okay yeah that's what i've always said
paris is like look like
i personally feel like as long as you
disclose it we're good it's like
you disclosed it you played it on easy
and another thing i've always been one
of those people it's like look like
with anything not just reviews like if
you don't like an influencer
and their kind of intake on something
just cross them off your list of people
you go to exactly i don't agree with
this like witch hunt that we got i think
it's like
that that part right there the fact that
i understand what you're saying paris um
you know if he didn't agree with it or
whatever or
the tweet shouldn't go out um you're
supposed to know how large you are
yeah as far as whatever tweet that you
do put out um sometimes we do
forget who we are yeah when we read
something and in this just don't press
send world we live in right now
sometimes we forget to not press send
and um i don't think it was done in any
malice
in in putting the tweet
i and i'm not speaking for colin i'm
speaking for the thought pattern behind
right if you're getting
paid to do reviews because you're
getting paid to do reviews
right if that's your job then you have
to disclose
all of this information going through
all right 100 percent agree on that yep
um if somebody and and if somebody's
opinion of the fact is
the majority of the people is going to
play it on normal i
understand exactly because me and
hip-hop talk uh prior to this
uh exactly about that whole thing
it doesn't change the game graphically
sound wise and you know and a little
other fidelities that is in that
category going forward
right but it does change a lot of the
review
depending on easy difficulty to normal
difficulty to hard difficulty
i'm in line with everything that
everyone's saying here i just felt that
you know colin is a bigger entity
sometimes we forget
not to press send and i and i understand
i don't think he like made it a big
thing because he went back you know to
clarify it
i just believe that the circles around
the people the followers around the
people
make the situation larger than what the
situation
actually truly is and their opinion
and it branches off into a whole bunch
of different variants
which wasn't intended by the initial
sender so
that's that's all i see here okay so we
all agree
because we're all in the same room we're
all in the same agreement
of the situation and i'm pretty sure if
colin is in the room he would be as well
right i'd agree with that i do feel like
you know
it is i just wouldn't call in twitches
when anyone tweets like anyone with a
massive amount of followers
you know when i read that tweet i didn't
necessarily take it that way but i'm
only myself i can't tell
other people to take tweets right so you
know when i'm looking at it i didn't
take it that way
but i'm glad colin came out and you know
like sometimes when you
when you have that kind of a following
you have so many people looking at you
because you have that kind of following
you do got to like you know kind of like
ask yourself
who's reading this how would they take
it and you got to like you know kind of
like
make sure that you're tweeting something
that's not going to get taken something
out of context
and it's like you know i'm going to say
something bg ankle guy bg up next
the full spectrum of this yeah cause
bg's on the other end i like
we gotta talk about completely out of
the spectrum i personally have never
been
like kite like you know i'm known as the
difficult game conquering you know bg
probably gonna agree with that but you
know
like i've always had that perspective
it's like when it comes to difficulty i
unders
as long as on a reviewing standpoint
they mentioned what how they reviewed it
what difficult they reviewed it on i'm
okay with that
and i've always on the on the other
adjacent i've never been
a uh you know kind of a gatekeeper of
difficulty like when people
every year they talk about the from
software games they're like oh this
needs to have
an easier mode i've always been that
kind of person if the developer wants to
do it to make their games more
accessible i'm not going to attack them
for doing because i know a lot of people
would
at the end of the day what's the
difference between having five different
difficulties on this spectrum
and what's the difference between them
doing it the only difference is is from
software is not giving you the option
right and it's like as long as they're
okay with it i wouldn't have an issue
with them doing it because
i could as long as the difficulty that
i'm going to play it on
is is still there and it's down scared
from that difficulty i don't care what a
difficulty is
right let's get um okay we gotta get the
full spectrum we got a little bg in the
building you know what i'm saying oh god
let's get it brother let's get it
because i love he's very outspoken
and i lo take some time so let's get it
bro like easy
difficulty reviewing you know i mean
where are you at with this whole thing
bro
uh so so i'll be the bad guy let's go
i know um i'm usually the bad guy so i'm
i'm
that's that's when i'm most comfortable
yes so listen you can you can play a
a game on whatever difficulty you want i
can't you know come to your home and
like push it too hard or not like that i
can't do that boys
i can't you know i can't i can't put
your difficulty on hard but
am i going to take your opinion on any
game absolutely not if you're playing on
easy
right i'm i'm not even taking you
serious especially if you're a reviewer
because
my thing is she said it and the lady
you're speaking about she said it in
such a like an
arrogant and lazy way that it implies
that she plays games just to get through
them and get her job done
and get the to get the review out that's
that's exactly how she sounded i'm not
playing a game not even on normal
because i just want to get through this
game get this review out get the game
i'm
so you're to me it sounded like she's
not even somebody who enjoys playing
games
because you're trying to rush through it
on easy so and i understand a lot of
these reviewers have
deadlines but why am i going to listen
to a review from somebody who's rushing
through the game
and just you using easy as a way to get
through it as fast as possible
let me let me i'm going to jump
in reference to that do you bg do you
think it's a
bigger issue is reference to
why maybe some reviewers feel pressured
to put it on easy like is that what you
say are you saying maybe a bigger issue
in reference to
for the reference to the industry and
let me ask you something real quick that
you can bounce off that
i've always felt like bg who you think
the bigger culprit is the
the the you know the the the sites that
put the
you know because they put a lot on a lot
of these reviewers they make them review
a lot of games so like to me
it's like maybe we need to restructure
that whole reviewing process thousand
percent
like because you know i understand she's
playing on easy but who
knows like she has probably she could
probably review 10 15 games that year
that that month so like her job is to
review games and if she can't
realistically get through the mall by
playing them all on normal it's like i
said i 100 percent play the game on
normal
100 on that but do you think it's more
on the person that's giving her the job
or more on the reviewer that's reviewing
the game
on the back end of it you know that that
is you know a problem
but workload yeah the workload issue but
at the same time that doesn't you know
excuse from excuse her from getting this
smoke i'm sorry it doesn't because
but because you are still like
arrogantly saying like yeah i'm going to
play all
right rush out and get to get this
review out and here's the thing here's
what's like
the mind-blowing thing i think you have
to be a certain type
if if you're not under some type of like
constraint time constraint
you're you're going you have to go out
your way to put a game on easy
because honestly the difference between
easy and normal nowadays in video games
is almost non-existent
it's non-existent so that means to tell
me you want like
app you literally want to walk through
the game because honestly on most games
normal is a walk through you don't
really have to try that much right so
you're going out your way to be
lazy and arrogant by even playing i want
to play devil's advocate with it because
you keep using these words like lazy and
arrogant
and those are your interpretations from
her words right
those words wasn't actually placed there
those are the interpretations that you
took from this
and you're placing the thoughts
on top of that i i i can i hear the
tweet
yeah can you can you read the tweet
because um
i just i i don't i just think is it kind
of a disservice
you know to to the individual because i
don't understand what type of workload
and i know what you're saying bg i
understand what you're saying
everything that you're saying in that
part what all right this this is
let me hear it so x psychonauts made the
announcement about invincibility mode
xbox then the xbox twitter account then
tweeted said beating the game on the
lowest difficulty is still beating the
game
then this um lovelady she had put um i
have never played a game
for review on anything but the easiest
difficulty
and i never will okay so there goes the
arrogance that that's pretty arrogant
i don't care i don't i don't hear the
lazy but i hear there goes the arrogance
okay and i feel i understand why
that tweet would start this i
understand that now so now sir
and let me just let me just make sure
some other things right
like i said like there's there's
virtually no almost no difference
between normal and easy
in in most situations right right and
like travis the reason
i got you i'll get my point i got to do
the reason i can't listen to you is
because yes i
with the i play 90 of my games on the
hardest difficulty
like 90 of them get out the gate two you
play it out the gate
out the gate second gate right are your
difficulty gatekeeping though fiji
no no but have some difficulty but
here's the thing
here's why here's why if you're a
reviewer while
what is why your review isn't thorough
it's because there's certain games
there's there's a there's a good amount
of games
that like what hip-hop said there's
there's certain games where the
difficulty is nothing but
you have less health the enemies do more
damage there's certain games like that
in their situations it doesn't matter
because they don't actually change
the gameplay but there's other games
that actually
change how the enemies behave there's
certain games that
depending on what you put the difficulty
on you you won't even see the enemies do
certain things
yeah it's like like flanking acting
right like this happens and this happens
in halo
and last of us it happens in x-com it
happens in call of duty
so you can't play that game on easy and
tell me anything
because you didn't see half of what was
happening let me give you a scenario
that i brought up to uh randolph thor
shout out to him
uh you know obviously you have games
like the last of us that is supplying a
lot more
you know accessible things and i love
that because it gives everyone an option
to play it
but right now we're talking about the
review state of the game like people
reviewing it
if someone plays something like the last
of us two and they put all of the
accessibility options on
and then they and they said that at the
beginning of the actual trailer it's
like it's like i said
nothing against the accessibility
options they need to be there because it
needs to give
everyone an option to play this but if
you're reviewing the game and you say
that at the beginning i played on easy
with every accessibility option on
my question to the panel is would you
continue watching that review
no are they disabled
no they're all enabled like it's
literally the easiest last of us
could be yeah and i think why are people
who are
fully and able-bodied people playing
with disability settings on
i don't even understand that so look i
mean i'll let you get your balls off and
finish if
you have the last book i got to get
travis in there we got a lot of people
in here
but um to your point i understand where
you're coming from bg i see what you're
saying a lot of people
chat do agree it's mixed but a lot of
people do agree as well but i gotta get
travis said as well because um
he works for a major publication when
they're gonna put his business out
travis do what we be talking about i'm
sorry
we're not gonna put his business out
there but he does review games you know
what i mean
and i'm very curious as a person who
that's
one of your jobs right so like travis
what are you feeling man like
how you feel about this whole reviewing
games on easy difficulty
yeah i think it's uh i think it's a
really complicated topic and i think
that there's a lot of
um eagerness online in particular for
people to create tribes
of you know one one extreme and another
extreme and then everybody jumps to that
side and i think that
especially when you have somebody like
colin who is a specific type of person
that a lot of people have strong
feelings about
uh it that makes it even easier to jump
into the sides and so i think
you know the original tweet from this
lady reviewer was just like you know
probably trying to be in people's face
about it and then colin did the same
thing and that that kind of made it
escalate but
yeah i i always try to take like the
middle ground approach like i'm not on
either side i think from a philos
philosophical standpoint
reviewers should be curious about games
and they should try to experience
everything about a game and so when i
review games i'm you know full
uh just transparency i am a try hard
like i also play on the hardest
difficulty and that's just myself
destiny that's all you need to know i
mean i also played dust tonight but
not that that game's happening say hello
thank you yeah
god bless but but like i i just think
that
there there is a point to to collin's
point i
i think colin actually does have a good
point in in certain regards because
you can miss certain parts of the game
and i actually have a story about this
okay
uh i worked i was writing reviews for a
different publication it was before i
worked for ign
there was a reviewer who was reviewing
persona 5
the original version that came out years
ago
and um when he published his review
he gave it a perfect score and i was
like wow this game must be amazing so
the game came out i played through the
entire game and as i was playing it
i don't know if any of you guys have
played persona 5 but it it it
has a lot of strengths i think it's a
great game but it also has
a lot of game design problems that they
fixed and persona
the royale version or whatever uh yeah
yeah
and one of the problems is that the
gameplay kind of has you guess people's
weaknesses
and if you don't guess their weakness
correctly on the first playthrough they
just like one shot you and then you have
to go back to a static checkpoint
and play through the entire section
again you lose like 30 minutes of your
time it's very frustrating
and so when i was playing through it i
was like god this is like really
irritating how did you go by this and he
goes
oh i played it on easy difficulty where
you can't die
right and he that was the only
difficulty he'd ever played it on and so
all of the problems with like the game
design which
the vast majority of players are
probably gonna have to experience he
didn't
experience and didn't have the curiosity
to even try it
and so his review was missing a lot of
that
it was it was incomplete it felt
incomplete to me and i was frankly like
shocked i was like
wow so you didn't experience any of the
gameplay you just skipped straight to
the screen how did that make you feel
it made me feel like i was just like he
played a different game than me
is no longer useful right and so right
uh and so i i think that there is a
point there where like in in certain
cases it's important to
to do to try different things but i
think you know
if you play halfway through a game on
normal difficulty and then you go okay
now i'm on a deadline let's switch it to
easy just to burn through because i
kind of know what the game feels like
that's different and if you try
different settings as i do i try to play
at least like an hour or two on every
setting just to
kind of understand but if your criticism
is saying like oh this game is
too easy and you only played it on easy
difficulty obviously that's a problem
they feel like
you know there's there it there's
there's it's more complicated than just
uh
black or white like if you write easier
dumb and if you play on hard then you
hate disabled people like that's not
the argument right and i think that yeah
it's very it's very different
yeah accessibility is a different thing
and i think that that blew up because of
who tweeted it right
right right just like i said yeah um but
yeah i honestly think that like
reviewers should be curious they should
they should try to remember that they
are trying to serve the readers they're
trying to
tell them what this game is about and
what to expect and they should try to do
everything in their power to provide
that service
and if they aren't doing everything then
the review is for them
and i don't think that that's your
reviews are for so i i have no problem
with people playing on the easiest
difficulty or the hardest difficulty i
just think that
reviewers should try to experience as
much of a game as possible to give a
really like fleshed out review
absolutely hey your point your point is
soft still with us because i want to get
him before he's here
yeah i'm here my battery's still i know
your battery's low
first you work in the ot you know so
bro what where are you at with this
whole thing easy you know easy game
difficulty
review um everybody made great points um
what i'll say is
um and somebody mentioned halo
since the first time i played through
combat evolved
are normal since then i have never at
least initiated not initiated a game in
hard mode
um because the difference from halo
combat evolved in normal to heroic
it we talked about enemies that flank
the intelligence of enemies the amount
of enemies
just the way the game reacts to your
movements and your actions is different
so from that moment on for me personally
i said okay i'm gonna at least start
every single game on hard
and then not every game gets that
balance perfectly right but i do think
there is
creative intent when you talk about you
know the the creators and what
the product that they put out they the
general experience they want
the consumer to have i think there is
something to that where when you start
changing
difficulty levels that gets altered and
the balance may not always be there
that's going to give you
what they consider to be the the the
prime general experience they're
expecting
the the consumer to have so um i i
and so in that regard i do think that
reviewers just need to be transparent
about
what they're playing on what's setting
their plan
and something and something that colin
says a lot is
no matter how you experience the game
when you talk about it and you're
critical of it
make that part of your thesis make that
make that a part of how you talk about
the game and at that point you're
contextualizing it
and everything you say is valid within
that context
and and and that makes sense to me so
what i
when it comes to reviewing and and how
you do it
just do that and for me what i hope this
argument has
has opened up the door to is for
there be a willingness to have different
types of reviews now where people are
going to be like okay
this is a review that's based on easy
mode with all these accessibility
settings on and what that means to a
person
you know what value that has to do with
certain types of gamers that's the power
supply for a certain type of gamer
right and i think all of it has validity
it absolutely 100 does
but i do agree with colin's point again
in the way colin says
sometimes it gets gets kind of uh people
uh
pull their eyes one way or the other
right but i do agree that if you're not
transparent about it i think the
assumption that most people
have when they read a review that
doesn't specify these things
is that they're playing it at at the
very least on the normal
difficulty that's going to give you the
the broadest experience that they expect
most players who purchase this game to
have and
maybe that's wrong on us for assuming
but i think that's
the way it's generally been so again i
think i think there's
there's space for every type of review
every type of difficulty level
um to have a voice and for it to be
valid right i just
before you go so i got to ask you this
because i know your badge is low what
what are your thoughts
on elitism in reference to it
and then i've seen the acts of
accessibility
argument come come to play with this
subject as well where are you at on
those two
things i i agree with travis completely
that's completely separate arguments to
get conflated because
people get in their feelings and all of
a sudden it becomes about
you know listen we've all seen
how you know the bad game of the
telephone that twitter can become yes
right mm-hmm where you have context
yeah yeah they're they're our favorites
oh yeah and by the time you're on
the end of the line by the time you get
to the end of the line
everything is is different and a lot of
people
will base their opinions on something on
a version of it that isn't necessarily
the truth fact
right and and not to say that we all
know the truth because there's always
you know there's one version there's
another version and somewhere in the
middle is the actual truth and not
very few times do is the actual truth
out there right there's always some sort
of nuance to it
so um to me listen there are two
different
issues that shouldn't be conflated i
mean i'm glad that colin came out and
clarified that because
obviously he's not he's not attacking
gamers with certain disabilities
that's an obvious thing but that is
something that people that want to
attack others
latch onto and sort of you know create
something bigger than what it is so
for me those conversations anybody who
engage who's engaging in that type of
discourse
and continues to push that button just
just mute them because it's not it's not
the problem
it's not the real issue that's what i
always felt so i was like look if you
don't agree with someone if you don't
agree of calling if you don't agree with
me
cog paris like just mute us or block
us don't don't
don't don't don't mute don't be kidding
me get kicked like that kick about that
think about that i'm just gonna take it
if you're sitting on twitter with this
much energy
go put it into something else man like
leave me alone
let's get it man you you you this is
your topic you know i gotta get where
you at with this you know what i'm
saying
i think i think it's it's a process
issue i
think it's a multiple different things i
think unrealistic timelines are put on
multiple different reviewers
i think some reviewers just want to play
it on easy because it's a job to them
and they're not really gamers they
you know they're hired that's not
necessarily because of their writing
skills i'm not necessarily their gaming
skills because i've seen that
throughout the years and you know at the
end of the day
i think some of it falls on the
publishers because they don't get review
copies out quick enough and
they're forcing people to rush through a
game
that's a good point no i i think i think
it's an industry-wide problem right
whereas like
now there's the race to to who gets the
first clicks right because who gets that
review out
thousand percent and the thing about it
is now that you know i think
travis can attest to this that now
because of the influence or because of
the youtube
youtuber and the and the influence that
they have now that that
that that playing field yeah hip-hop as
well that
playing field has been leveled where it
isn't necessarily the case where the big
outlets are getting the review code
early and
you know this you know a guy with with
500 000 subscribers on youtube
may have that record before you right um
so it's it you know it's a
it's a race for the clicks and
unfortunately that means that you have
to rush through a game a lot of times
and potentially travis again i i'm not
trying to get you in any type of trouble
id
i was gonna say like because of this
coach obviously let me see you have a
website right
so there are times when the game comes
in
you know say a game release on a tuesday
right you may get that review called
monday right because you know you're not
there are occasions where you will
right you're not the bigger outlet or
whatever you might get it tuesdays
yeah you might get a twitter so let me
let me ask you real quick before you ask
in that
do you think that like some publishers
developers they might
okay you know our game might do good
might not do good let's give it to them
the day before so they rush through the
game and that's right
i know where you're going i know you go
that's a whole nother i don't know
yes i think that happened that's the w
we're gonna get today we're gonna get to
that but travel i do want to ask you
this i want to bring back you because at
the end of the day
you know we're talking about a systemic
culture that
may pressure people to bg's point like
to
you know say hey i got so much on my
plate and i got the hottest game
it's gonna launch tomorrow the embargo
is out right
and if i do this as quick as it and
efficiently as possible
that would lead to my site getting
first and and clicks and traffic like so
that's why i said there's levels
i think i think it's sometimes a problem
uh i don't think it's a problem for ign
because ign you're always going to look
at our review like if you care about a
game like ign is kind of like on your
checklist of like outlets to read
reviews from
in my mind right they do that yeah i
don't i go to lords of the game
listen listen that's the 100 truth
in my experience it's unless you're like
a smaller outlet where like you the only
thing that's going to distinguish you is
how quickly you get it out
people really don't care too much about
the timing i mean obviously it's ideal
to get it out as close to the embargo or
release date as you can depending on
what you're working with
but i actually think that the opposite
is happening where now people are liking
longer reviews that are like an hour
long video where you're like doing a
deep dive and
those take a little bit longer to come
out and i think the diversity and kind
of the types of reviews
are solving a lot of that problems
obviously there's always going to be
that like quick and dirty like
oh i want to get this out as quickly as
possible but take skyward sword hd i
just got done reviewing that i only had
four days to play it it's a 50-hour game
so i and i just like gave you know it
fell on the sword get my whole weekend
of just playing that game to get it out
of the door
yeah i i did not i did not
um put the review out before i had
finished playing the game because ign
has a hard rule on that you have to
finish beating the game and so
uh what i did was because i wasn't gonna
make embargo i did a review in progress
we got
hundreds of thousands of clicks and then
when i put out the full review it
happened again so we actually got to
double dip
and i don't think that that hitting the
time frame thing is really a
a a problem for most like established
outlets
you know maybe for some smaller
streamers i just i honestly don't think
it's that big of a deal i think that uh
however long it takes you to give an
actually useful
opinion and help share what you found
that's how long it takes and most of the
time unless it's like
you know a week later people don't
really don't really care too much so you
know what the bigger question is travis
did you beat skyrocker on easy
listening to everybody's point all right
and and i'm going to like key on a
little bit on travis point
i think perry said something oh yeah
paris has
when it comes to this rule all right and
i i really believe that we're
missing the topic here and i'm going to
get that back back to the point but
you're the real exception when you get
to this rule alex brought up a point
a lot of these guys are brought in
because of their writing skills
and not because of their gaming skills
and maybe the gaming skills are
secondary
to their writing skills and the a plus
and they're given a game
to do and given a short time frame to
get it done
you are a gamer gamer
a whole weekend with a 50-hour game and
you knock it out
and you can write you understand
i think that most people who become
reviewers even if they're not like
tryhards like me the reason they get
hired is not because of their ability to
write
just in general it's about their ability
to analyze and
explain games and give opinions on like
how they work in the mechanics it's your
ability to break apart
games
i'm disagreeing that they just get hired
for being a writer i i agree with you
that they don't get
hired because they're good at games i
didn't have to take a test like oh did
you get all these
girls okay what was your start with
mario
you're talking from them you had a
gaming sat
that wasn't part of your absolute
testing you know you know what they did
they lock travis in a closet and make
him play checker
on the heart that's right that's right
yeah you're talking from there
they didn't check my gamers
the big status where i'm talking from uh
joe's joe blows reviews
reviews see but joe blow reviews is just
starting up
right oh yeah
yeah but joe blow reviews happen to get
a gem in you right right i understand
and you're happy about the scene and
taking some place else but how many gems
did he have to how many uh lumps of coal
did he have to go through to get a gym
you understand and then at the same
point your
viewpoint of it is skewed to your
viewpoint of it
my viewpoint of it being that i'm not a
reviewer and i'm just a game player
it's this is this i can tell you that a
lot of these dudes don't play games
they don't do it and i know they don't
do it but they can write their butt off
i can't but i can play a game this is
why we have a website and i'm not a
reviewer
this is this is exactly the exact reason
why but attic can do that
because i cannot do that well no no
[Laughter]
when you're playing a game and you're
streaming
you don't know that you're actively
reviewing the game while you're playing
you're doing that so don't talk about it
there you go
all right so anyway back to what i was
saying to you
um i'm trying to explain that sometimes
people are put in positions where
that's above their head right and when
they have to and when when certain
people are put in those positions
they take the lowest easiest route
through
right to get it done now workload
is an issue short date like tomorrow the
review got to come out and you just get
the game today
if you're not a great game player it
might be difficult for you
so you got to go on an easy thing the
only thing that i'm a key back in
on and i'm going right back to what bg
say when he said the arrogance when i
read the tweet or heard the tweet read
i've never
played a game on any difficulty but easy
and i never
will when somebody tells you a
definitive thing like they never will
that's an arrogance in that stance that
you're gonna say
that i'm not even gonna try you
understand so
i can understand where everything came
from this one little tweet
and maybe that might rub somebody else
wrong
now the person that said that we know
this should not oppress sin because
he's larger than that tweet
you understand and the people around him
even if they're not as large as him he
has he has a
caravan behind him you understand that's
how this gets blown out of proportion
she's not as large as the individual
that tweeted back at her
and changed a whole different narrative
around it so
i'm empathizing with the individual
because i don't know her circumstance
right but the circumstance got blown out
of proportion because
one person who is larger
retweeted something and it at it
shouldn't have and and then and it
doesn't matter because
he was just given his opinion he went
back to clarify his opinion
and it's not a big thing it's a it's a
bigger issue
in this space with time constraints
uh uh resume as far as reviewing games
and getting stuff done
right but again it's the wild wild west
so whoever you
like and you love their uh the way they
review games
you you like that person yeah you go to
that you pick the ones that you like
a hundred thousand clicks was it because
you was at ign
it's because they wanted to go to you
right now i feel like
let's get out of there shout out azj in
the building no i said shout out to acg
he's he's definitely one of my go-to for
reviews for sure
oh i'm sorry real quick the mine's gonna
be real quick and then i'll go i gotta
respect travis because i try to do that
review thing when the website first came
out
i can't do that travis no not even
remote
like homeboy will hit me up with all
kinds of random like fam i don't want to
see rat
like i don't care about the red take
your red and go home
and you know when it comes to the
calling tweet it's like i said
you know i think everyone needs to be a
little bit more
uh you know when reading a tweet how is
everyone else going to react to it like
when i read it i felt like he was just
saying
you know she plays it on easy mode you
know i feel like if you're playing every
game on easy mode
you're not enjoying what you're doing
and that's how i took it
uh i didn't really take her tweet to her
because like i said when it comes to the
difficulty thing
i'm not uh a difficulty gatekeeper i
don't care what you're playing on yeah
i'm just not gonna watch your content
mm-hmm
no i feel like perhaps you want to get
something before i go or you're good
yeah
just all the points that have been been
made
been fantastic um a couple different
points first of all this entire thing is
just messy
it's all just messy right because i
understand and again i'm not not trying
to talk out of pocket about colin
because
honestly this isn't truly about him
right it's about
the conversation that that this started
right whereas
what natalie said yeah that was arrogant
what she said 100 bg was spot on with
that because
she shouldn't have said that as a
reviewer don't sit there and tell me
that you're
never going to play a game on anything
except easy because
like you're saying i am not going to
engage with your
content because clearly you're telling
me you're not
you're not the content that i'm going to
go look for because i think a lot of us
here are quote-unquote tryhards because
we all play destiny
so we play games for the challenge of it
right
but but i will say one thing that that
came out of this that made me think um
we're actually previewing the game right
now and
we're not going to meet it at at the
deadline we're going to hold the content
until later on because we don't want to
rush through it
to meet the deadline we want to be able
to take our time and talk about it
you know you know without without
without it being rushed
but i'm also playing it at the normal
difficulty because i literally just
started playing and didn't change the
difficulty
now in my head i have to make sure i
disclose that i do
feel like that is something that came
out of all of this
that i think that does need to be an
interesting great
from now on you are playing a game just
say what the difficulty is
that's it that's it it's literally that
simple and then
if i'm a hardcore guy and you're playing
on easy or normal oh i don't want to
deal with that i'm gonna go find the
dude that's playing that's
hard you go there you go hip-hop i know
you won't get it my bad
yo all right yo everybody's doing
amazing
this show is fire right first off but
i'm gonna break down like three things
and then
you know like yeah that's what we do
yeah right so the first thing is this
right
i've been talking about this for the
longest time i'm gonna break it down
step by step let's go so
whenever i play a game you gotta know
the personality of who's reviewing
see one of the biggest problems in the
industry is that you have somebody that
talks about the game but the person
that's talking about the game wasn't who
played the game
that's a big difference so whenever i
like playing any game i'm reviewing
stuff you're seeing my first ever
reaction to playing the game
so if they're saying i don't know you're
gonna see me not know and then you're
gonna see me figure it out you're gonna
see me this and then you're gonna know
what i genuinely
like and what i generally don't like
because it's all based off first
impressions so you can see my natural
reaction on how i react to games so when
you see me play dark souls and
bloodborne
everybody knows i don't like those games
i'm terrible i understand why they're
great i can't separate the feeling from
the fact
if i use cheat codes on those games on
this game
but but at the end of the day people
still want to see it and see the
progression and they
enjoy my energy like you know what i'm
saying just having fun on the stream and
that right there is valuable to them
because they still see in the game
and that's what it is they're seeing
something that they don't own right
personally so that's one right the
transparency of the actual person that
you're following
that plays a major role so that's one
second thing right
when you are um uh when i
uh play games with cheat codes right you
actually learn
more on top of what travis was talking
about you
actually learn even more of the game
when you use cheat codes i'll give you a
great example
so i'm playing dark alliance right on
xbox uh uh uh
gamepad stuff like that right so you
said weird
oh my god
so i'm playing the game right so when
i'm playing so when i'm playing the
joint
um i gotta set to where uh um i got my
point my skill points is 99 i'm at the
highest level
everything out the gate right and i'm
playing on the hardest difficulty
now what people don't know is immortals
phoenix rise in a lot of these games
i'm playing them on the hardest
difficulty right because i got all the
cheat codes on it so i can't die
so i'm playing the game right and when
i'm playing it
um i'm learning things about the game
that i'm like yo
now i see how they hustle you now see
how they hustle you
so i'll give you example right look at
assassin's creed you know why they sell
time saver packs
because they purposely made the game a
certain way so you could feel like you
need to buy these time saver packs
extra points and everything like that
right so that's one so then
secondly if let's say you're um i'm
playing uh uh
the game i'll say about dark alliance
when you play this game on the hardest
level
the hardest level right a regular
npc a regular goblin it took me over
200 hits you could just beat a regular
person not a boss
not another just a regular goblin to me
200 hits
with me at the highest level on the
hardest difficulty
so you got to understand that when it
comes to the goblin was giving you work
no obviously i won you know what i'm
saying but the thing is the point i'm
trying to make
is you get to learn certain things about
a game because you kind of like break
the game and see how it is internally
right
and so when you even get that experience
it's one of those situations where it's
like
where's the there's a there's a line you
got to draw between fun and annoying
right right you know what i'm saying if
i'm playing the game at the end of the
day
because that's one of the review
categories fun factor
that's the most important if you ain't
having fun i don't care about nothing
else oh for sure
and and you know what i'm saying so
that's the second thing i wanted to
bring up in terms of fun factor
however you have your fun that's it
because not everybody that's playing
uh uh world of warcraft is trying to be
an esports player
i ain't playing to have fun and let you
know
what this game has and you experience
what you want experience but this is
what the game has in it
check it out boom done then one more
thing i got in my mind i got you
guys yeah can we talk about dark
alliance
[Music]
the last thing i wanted to point out in
terms of just uh reviews and uh
disclosing everything and stuff like
that
um earlier uh i forgot who said it but
it was my elitism
i think you talked i think you said that
you asked the question about
elitism um one of the things that i
always say
is look if you want to experience the
hardest difficulty or something like
that
i tell people like yo when it comes to
that cynical way of debating and talking
like when i'm playing fighting games in
particular it's always on the hardest
level
it's me versus you and i'm nice right
period so
i go online everything like that and we
battling each other definitely
competition
yeah the ultimate the ultimate
competition of anything is who you going
against
so i tell everybody if you want that
smoke and you want to talk about
difficulty
let's utilize our skills against each
other and see who's really easy and
who's really hard
from that club you know like that's
that's another thing i was going to say
in terms of the elite elitism
thought process no i'll get with you
there's no need for that i got it
because i know it's time to hear my
weapon so we got to get b
bg bro yeah yeah i know yeah i got a lot
of people in here so i don't want to you
know
not you understand but but the last
point i was going to make is and
and you know um they've alluded to it
like
you should king alluded to it like you
should know the people
that you're listening to that's i think
that's the most important thing
like like he's talking about going to
ironlords.net and everything like that i
mean like that that's what you gave it
down there get it right get it right
i actually got it i actually got it on
my bookmark no no no no
i appreciate it i already know your
support for the game nobody
so that's what you should do because you
go there because you know
who it is that wrote and reviewed it
like
when like i know y'all people talk about
like acg and a lot of
you know popular independent reviews i
don't listen to none of them right
simply because not because they're bad
reviews but simply because i don't know
them and i don't know what they value
when it comes to games
okay when when i want to know if a game
is good i usually if i don't play it
myself
i go to somebody i know like like jack
move for example or somebody
like if it's that relationship when you
trust that you
know the type of games exactly and vice
versa i feel and for example like if
it's an rpg because i only like
certain type of like you know very
specific type of rpgs right
and there's people that i know that are
like rpg heads
i go to them and i don't ask them what
you think about the game i actually do
you think
i would like the game that's what i ask
i don't i don't care about what you like
you know me you know me what i like it
that's the only thing i ask people
because i've established what i like
around here already so i just asked them
what i like
that's the most refugees they're
probably going to say bg this one's not
for you
and just to add in so what bg's saying
because this is so true
um even when i like when i stream the
the
blood boards and those types of games i
tell people on my stream
i tell people like yo like i'm not the
one
to come
i'm like yo i'm not the person to take
like uh advice from one of
these games i don't like these games i'm
only playing them because
i got cheat codes and i can get through
them
the graphics is fire and i don't gotta
die all the time
but you're transparent you know what i
have to that's all i'm saying
you know what i have to give you hip-hop
i remember when that cuphead thing went
down
and i remember you was the topic
everywhere man every podcast
and money my exact sentence every time i
was like you guys want people to lie and
do it
facts because that was like because
people's words
me and kid smooth was watching that the
whole night like
like literally hip hop did what no one
else could do he got everyone in there
he's like man hip hop is stupid here i
got these chicos
it's gotta love him though to the point
where
he knew people like who wasn't using
cheat codes for a couple minutes no
doubt paris and then i did i got to get
my balls off him
yeah yeah yeah cause i because i'm
because i want to drop out yeah no doubt
brother
do some stuff so i just want to say
there's one last thing on it me
personally again
my opinion this entire review
process hustle all the way from the top
with ign all the way down
to the smallest streamer is is it's the
biggest
side hustle ever think about it because
all this stuff is tied in metacritic
talk about it all this russian
honestly i think the entire thing needs
needs to be redone because we're in an
era now
again it honestly goes to exactly what
bg was talking about he
trusts the people that he knows and he
has a relationship with them so that's
who he's going to
to find out if he should have a game
right or play a game right
most people don't have that luxury so
they have to go with what they see out
there and the way the system
is set up right now is these sites get
these games
they might get it a week early they
might get it three weeks early they
might get it the day of they're rushing
to put these reviews out
yes and they're not truly and again you
know
to travis here i'm not saying that you
do this specifically but i'm just saying
the overall sentiment is
they're not truly putting their best
foot forward while they're playing these
games because
they're trying to hurry up and get to
the end so they can put the review out
so they can get the clicks and the
scores and all that systemic yeah
yeah i think i think part of the way you
mitigate that is to start is to try to
sort of uh
take away this the power of the of the
numbered review
because i think it's the numbers when
you force people to read through and
just sort of get specific points on on
on the written article about the game or
whatever i think
yeah the number stuff starts starts to
matter less and then maybe the rush to
get that number out
i hate the i hate the numbered reviews
yeah i don't do doubles
i always hear one last point
because i do got to support that one i
want to make it i absolutely hate the
numbered
score with reviews because at the end of
the day it's an opinion
yes that's all any of this is it is an
opinion
my opinion is no more valid than
creation
i'm just telling you my perspective on
when i play a game and you should go
seek out the persons whose
perspective lines up with you and the
way you want to play games i think
that's all this stuff is so when i see
look because i know i catch it all the
time about cyberpunk and all this stuff
right
yellow chat gang we can't listen to
no but think about that game as an
example yo it was getting tense
it was getting tense wondering why
because everyone rushed to go review it
because they wanted to be first
and the way that cd projekt red set up
the review process
and we all know it's a three or four at
best pretty good preacher
instead of getting the actual real
opinion right you're well
it's a 10 it's a 10. that's tied to the
bonuses and all that and we
rigged the system so that you were going
to give it a 10 because we give gave it
to you in a rush statement in a rush
state
and with a restricted something some
reviewers
get them in a restrictive state you can
only talk about up until this point
and that point and that's a whole other
thing but look let me just get my balls
off because this is you know first of
all
real quick let me let me just i'm going
to dip out yeah i'm on live support
right now
love y'all next week
listen first of all i love you all
because these are the discussions
i love iowa podcast for that all of us
can have different opinions
and be respectful get your bars off and
it's still
love so first of all even the bad guys
you know what i'm saying
shout out to travis you know i don't
want nobody to get in trouble but we all
being respectful so salute to that
that's number one
number two look i i love everything i'm
saying to hip hop
you know i'm when i'm on you know with
the cheat code i don't have a problem
with that you know i'm saying like
that's a non-issue to me like that why
would you choose to pursue the game it's
your business business
you know i'm saying no one should
dictate that you know what i'm saying
and then as far as you know everything
as far as the um
what paris was saying which was really
great about you know the systemic issue
that we're seeing you know i'm saying in
reference to
the review process and and how we could
potentially change that and stuff like
that
and i gotta shut my man travis out man
because he has some bars
it hits for me personally i'm an older
gamer right so
listen with the review thing 100 percent
y'all got to be transparent to me it's
it's it's no different
than checking the box to say you played
it on series x or you played it on
playstation 5
it should also say you played it on easy
or you played it on whatever difficulty
it is
in my opinion this is where i do have to
defend colin on this part
normal based on statistics right and
trophies
normal is generally the default setting
that the majority will experience again
i'm not
saying anybody's wrong for reviewing
that easy that's their right that's
their privilege
just disclose it just disclose it and i
think that's what's great about this
conversation
is that this might start to generate
that kind of discussion and that kind of
thing
i think it would i think it would after
after doing this i'm pretty sure
a lot of the people that are in position
to tell them what is a requirement
for when you're doing this review hey
listen just disclose
what level that you played on yeah
that's it and it really shouldn't
matter right unless you're afraid that
you're gonna lose
that
i'm old school at the end of the day i'm
gonna get a little metal right now but i
gotta be real
like to me difficulty
kind of can shape you as a gamer and as
a person to be able to go through
a challenge right so my thing is like
for example y'all know cognito with
shinobi that's my joint right
back in the day that game was the dark
souls arcade of
one hit you out of there you don't say
it didn't matter what the ninja hit you
the bullet hit you
is i that game was taking your money
physically for not being good at it
and i remember going to arcade and there
was this kid they dawned in the hood
they used to call [ __ ] over dawn
right i was like yo he could beat that
joint with one quote like i
idolized this kid if i'm like i thought
he was the illest dude
i was like yo i gotta have this game but
at the end of the day to that point and
to also the fighting games point
can you know where we come from you know
what i'm saying you get your butt
whipped
you got to get in the door get that
second character whatever whatever
i feel a little bit of it does build
character you know what i'm saying
i do feel that you know i'm saying again
how you review it is how you review it
all i want to say is the last one i want
to say is this i don't think we touched
on
is i just don't want devs to be forced
into it if they don't want to like to me
the whole this is video games to me is
art from software right
and and it's not my right my opinion
right to say yo you have to put an easy
mode in this you have to
because my thing is if the developer
wants to do it
great if he doesn't it's okay too
because it might be
not every game is for everybody
everybody you know what i'm saying
and there's some games that i'm not i'm
not good in them dark souls game i'm not
stressing myself up you know what i'm
saying
i'm not i'm sorry i'm not doing shout
out to attic that's all
them they could have
you know what the key to everything is
that we can get everything fixed so it
says
we can go to that website change.org
shut up your phone last week we'll
finish up look
great discussion i think and to solve's
point in the king's point i think
accessibility is a
completely different subject i know many
of you travis had talked about that
we're not being disrespectful to anybody
there you know what i'm saying the main
thing is
exactly just transparency you know what
i'm saying play and respect the game is
that the game reviewers that you want to
respect
and that's all i got but that's what we
got we gonna move oh we got super chats
though we gotta get
a couple of them if you want yeah you
know what i'm saying but then we got to
get the hot ones way many
way money winning oh my god they just
keep coming in
the bushes so we might have to get it
later because it's that type of show
but anyway but anyway so look this is a
big one i know
king is ready for this oh yeah
uh june 2021 npd xbox series x and s
consoles led in dollar sales nintendo
switch sold the most units
so um shout out to windows central shout
out to my man uh sam tober i guess he
had put this out i'm
reading from him he didn't finish it
though oh this boy is
playstation 5 was the fastest to sell oh
what
okay the series x and s consoles were
the best sellers for
the month in dollar sales setting a new
record for xbox sales
in june the nintendo switch retained its
streak as the best
selling console in unit sold and yeah so
this is the topic that king
wanted to talk about so uh king you're
feeling sir or the series x and jude mpd
why is your change sir what is going on
you got to talk to the people so they
can see this i need to get a necktie
with that on it
ah all right guys stand up this is where
you get your brand next up
i just told y'all for a very long time
a lot of dudes were telling me phil
dominance maximus is really expensive
wasn't the one
when i called him dominus y'all was like
nah he ain't earn that when i call him
maximus you're like can you bug him when
i call him aurelius he can't be the
golden one king what are you talking
about
baby 10 years of being down we up
oh we up now we up now okay we
up now now see if they're in this game
to make money right
so you being the fastest you just being
the fastest to the loss oh my
you saw the units you're just selling
the most units at a loss
if i'm ready if i move this mic
but we doing this for the cash
we doing this for the bucks uh-huh we
ain't selling the fastest
we ain't selling most units how the hell
we make the most money
oh that's about the bill this is
millions talk now that's what we're
doing
so since y'all are numbers dudes cause
you numbers dudes is on my timeline
please please tell me
how did this happen how did that be how
did this happen
how did this happen
how did microsoft make more money by
selling less by being slower
how because their units cost more you
know why
you know why because phil dominance max
spencer knows why he knows why
okay and should i open up the book of
action would you read the good
scriptures
let's turn deuteronomy chapter three
it's gonna burn their tummy because you
know nintendo don't care
about a lot of things but you know what
so many dudes care about
yo we was number one in the mp no you
was
oh my god he was the fastest one at the
store
that's it and you sold at a loss
you messing that's it you messy sir no
again
i waited for this moment it took 10
years
i knew who was going to get me to this
spot this was all fulfilled
this is over oh my god this is on the
field
so phil you're watching
who did that for you
who did that before you fell down he
broke the street king
he broke the street who broke it though
how many people
had stepped up to that plate and didn't
break the street
who broke that street that's true and
see and i know you
and you know you know what makes it more
impressive to me
what makes it most impressive the game
that y'all was hyping up
oh lord the ssd only you tell ratchet
ratchet and clank which one which one
game which one game or the
other boss but it ain't winning no money
they can win everything you want to win
but they still came up short
at the checkout line so again
what did we come in with game pass pain
pass
because you got a brand new game it's
lit what you got game
it's a game oh it's a game passes that's
what we do game passes
hey xbox series sns they all yo listen
money's moving it's just moving in one
direction
and other dudes see money and they're
like we're fast though
but how come we can't make that money
like that though because you ain't got
phil he got filled down with this fan
fan that kid got his bars off he was
waiting
he was waiting for this let's get him
popping man
[Music]
um well first of all i mean it's great
for them you know what i'm saying uh
it's one of those uh moments where it's
like
look it's not about the fact that we got
here it's about how do you stay there
right yeah and that's that's the key
what are you gonna do to stay there it's
like in school you get a hundred
but can you maintain a hundred for the
whole four years in high school
like y'all saying there's a difference
so my thing is what i would say is uh
what would be impressive to me
in terms of this particular stat on the
month is if
as if they can if they can do this for
like
another three months then that means
that they was able to do it for a whole
season i feel consistently
if if they do it for a whole season
consistency consistently
now you can actually build a actual
reference and a testimony to what you're
doing is right
in terms of going on that trajectory so
that's the first thing don't make it a
hot line make it a hot show continue
there it is exactly you know
the second thing is like um because
y'all got to understand like people that
being a feeling is like can't be trolley
like yeah
yeah you know you know you don't but i
want to say something that's
very important that like makes that's
really making sense
so when you look at the top 10 gaming
companies
period as of march 2021
the top 10 gaming companies in terms of
like revenue generated
specifically for gaming revenue gaming
division that's it uh sony is number one
with 25 billion you know i'm saying 10
cent is number two
um nintendo's number three and microsoft
is number four xbox is number four
so to me what i feel like xbox should uh
really focus on
is how to consistently move up right in
those particular ranks
and the reason why is because i just did
a video
talking about the 360 era so when was
that when did they come out
one day what come out that that that
that um chart that you was talking about
with sony was number one with 25 billion
when did that come out
um this is based off of i think march on
21st
what was that that's when maternal came
out
i don't remember don't know this is over
time like this
yeah this is like bit like based on from
you know when they came out all the way
over time
because tencent was number one for a
long time yeah we we
don't know about tencent we ain't gonna
look at them we're gonna talk about
those three that we talked about
this isn't like an mpd thing this is a
career
period all right so i just i just want
to give you one caribbean
one one caveat okay sony games is crazy
right they they're
incredible they have a nice catalog
right um microsoft
took 7 billion when i got these studios
we gearing up guns is ready stuff is
coming
we're doing this all natty
just walking in the gym no no trainer
grabbing the weights and we flexing with
you we fall we looking at you you got a
trainer you're an olympic star you got
you got endorsements those are the vegas
those are the ratcheting collectors
oh gym bag i just came back to like
crazy stuff going on
right here
the person the person coming to the gym
like that they're going to get the
hernia first
yeah you understand what we're saying
you know you see what it is is
that dude that's coming in there he's
hungry though
he hungry though and he's looking at you
and he's seeing what you doing to be
successful
so he realized you got a trainer
you got a hell of a gym equipment bag
you got that pre-workout
and i see you got a crazy meal prep i've
been eating mcdonald's let me cut that
out
yo let me cut that out oh
you hitting that treadmill he watching
you he's studying you
uh-huh so to your point
these games is coming big halo down the
block
he picked your style free to play
he saw what you was doing before with
the free to play stuff and we had a
barrier let's remove that
because they don't do that over there i
see he actually picks up the little
weights too let me get those
you understand when you mimic somebody
and you study in your prey
i'm just telling people this is
foreshadowing what is it so this is the
start of
oh no this is the same foreshadowing get
it here
so here's what i would say like you know
let's deal with facts because
you know that's how we that's how we
post this yeah
so let's get to the facts like the fact
is this
um with what xbox is doing
is great and when i was talking about
the 360 era um i made a video
talking about how the serious x like
that is so the sirius x
to me is taking it to another level
beyond what the 360 era had
and it's very important because what
siriusx is doing
is they are getting involved and
embedding their brand
with the with the movement of the
community so for example
and this is where um uh playstation has
to
don't fall don't fall from so
when the refrigerator situation happened
right
where they people made fun of emma
greenberg the webcam was messed up the
fridge in the back
they made fun of that so instead of
being corporate and taking yourself so
serious
and trying to act like you're a product
or not they they made themselves human
right you know what i'm saying as a
brand and now that's why you get the
actual refrigerator
now you got the actual uh 90s music
video we're all for one
like that's how you that's how you get
these things because they are
a part of the community so it's like
yeah we did something funny but now
we're going to flip it
that's how we move now with playstation
right when they came out with the um ad
and the playstation was upside down they
they took it away and try to make it
seem like it didn't happen
so now you're trying to make it seem
like you're something you're not which
is perfect nobody's perfect
and those very those very things is what
allowed 360 to beat
sony in america even though globally
they lost overall
so to me what i think xbox should really
focus on
is the more they focus on what they're
doing
that would be the only shot that they
actually have to potentially
uh dethrone playstation but let's keep
it real
all facts they're not the playstation no
listen listen playstation
um if we and i'm talking about this from
a standpoint of direct competition
so we all know we we all know nintendo
is uh oh yeah
which definitely but like mike tyson is
a heavyweight division yeah he don't
fight roy jones
i'm just messing with you
yeah but in the sport it is for the
boxing
you know you got your heavy weights and
you got your middleweights and your
featherweights and stuff like that
so when it comes to sony and microsoft
it's heavyweights
and since sony existed it says microsoft
existed
sony never took any else microsoft only
took else
so so i think right now in this
generation
right right now in this generation
microsoft i don't think they're looking
to beat
playstation i think are looking to win
your time as a gamer and if they win the
time
of time spent as a gamer engagement then
the engagement
then i think that's gonna make them
valid that's gonna make them grow and if
they have that overplay station
that could be a victory facts box no
doubt let's get uh mr travis in here man
what are you feeling about xbox series x
dollar sales uh winner in mpd for the
month of june
where are you at with this whole day
yeah i mean i
i play primarily on xbox but i own all
the consoles and don't i don't really
have a horse in this race in terms of
like who i want to win or whatever
uh although i will say i do enjoy being
an xbox gamer more when they are the
underdogs because they tend to do things
that
are better when they're not you know the
head of the pack
so yeah i like it when they're hungry um
that said i actually think this headline
is great news for all of the
uh platform owners because it shows that
like
the gaming space is now large enough
that everyone can succeed playstation
can be fastest selling xbox can have
what that doesn't
mean nintendo it just it just means that
the days of nintendo vs sega no no i
mean no no
very
it means that the units they had
disappeared the fastest
meaning you know that goes what i was
saying
now i can't find it either don't do that
[Laughter]
the i think the thing here is that like
we live in a world where
all three of these companies can be
wildly successful and although they're
competing with one another they're not
fighting with lethal weapons anymore
they've got their
their blasters turned to stun right like
you're not going to go out of business
if we beat you it's no longer nintendo
versus sega and sega has to
you know crash their console because
nintendo is successful everyone can
succeed in different areas and
and it makes uh the the marketplace
better without anybody having to you
know go to business and i think that's
awesome
and that's be that's because gaming has
grown so much now
i mean like look at this this this week
we had the switch oled
sell out and the steam deck sell out a
day apart from each other
and the steam deck we knew it was coming
before the switch came out and it still
sold out and that's because
the gaming space is so robust there's
room for everyone to be successful
i still think xbox wants to win i
disagree with hip-hop i think xbox wants
to
beat playstation of the ground but i
think that their
their their goal isn't to just
obliterate sony as a company or like
make their console not around it's
that they're i think phil spencer is a
person who knows
he knows that his company is better
because of the competition that
playstation brings to the table
and i honestly think he sees the value
in that and so i i think it's
it's you know everybody's fighting with
with their stunners turned on actually
okay no
the gun the guns is out okay so that
that's stunner stuff
no nobody's out there instead of steve
austin the people no no we're trying to
take them out
we're trying to give the bob backlin
back breaker
we're trying to get you out the game the
reason why i can say this is because
mlb to show a first party sony game
launched on game pass for free
that's a lethal shot to the head that's
a lead through shot to the head that's
not i'm like
you actually think so yeah yeah i mean
you think that's the shot
how is that a lead through shot okay
playstation's still in business
no no all you're doing is all right
making me look better on your own
platform all right cool
that's right that's like that's like
when um
no let's go all into this trap is hold
into a trap don't do this
this trap is wild i'm giving you so
listen so listen
the lead through shot right so since you
said it's a lethal shot
what was the outcome what was the
results what is the proof you people
realizing that the fact that you are
going to be better developers on our
platform oh my
god really playstation actually
reverting to back to where we found them
at when it was developing
playstations before they made consoles
before they made consoles they were
out here making video games we don't
want you we want y'all to be the best
hold on
hold on because right now that
playstation 5 is underpowered over the
price and slow
oh here we go
here we go hold up hold on
right now
you
xbox also started making software just
like sony
oh my god talking about it is
xbox was the side project right
democracy now they looked over
microsoft actually looks over at my at
xbox it's something totally different
rebranding everything everything is
different
it's a whole different system that's
going in place everybody keeps talking
about
old microsoft old microsoft mm-hmm
y'all not the same old sony oh here we
go
can i say something real quick i'm gonna
say something right now i don't even got
this i'm gonna say something right now
hold up hold up because people are going
no no accountability has to happen right
now
accountability has to happen right you
gotta find out
hold up before before playstation 5 and
before
xbox series x and s dropped there was a
lot of promises
and there was a lot of things set yeah
or you turn on your xbox series x
there's no game
there's no game on xbox there's no game
on xbox right now
right now let me get my game look at my
guns they're shooting
yo yo let's go
there's nothing no i'm not let's give it
to my last comments give it a buck
there's nothing there's nothing yet on
xbox
and we like seven uh eight months in
there's nothing on xbox that shows
sell one of ours and make more than
yours too
this is crazy are you serious you're
selling two
you fast out the door making less money
selling one and making more money i'm
done
yo we can go we could go like let's go
to ratchet and claim real
nothing that we made
that looks like ratcheted
the best game we got games that look
better than movies right now bro
you got tech demos come on he's trying
to figure out where shawna because i
need that old sony feel
that i do is looking real different
dance moves running you got petitions to
get the dude
y'all yo right now
he talking about moving to pc he
actually a flag nexus
nexus
i got i got to stop the shooting yo
y'all
that was classic bars great great
discussion
on dollar sales is a straw metric i'll
give king that you know what i'm saying
but at the end of the day look like
travis said everybody's winning
different you know i said and like
everybody's you know what i'm saying
like for
the fact that microsoft's doing the game
pass thing unless we realize they have
like a major release out like sony had
you know saying for them to do that
it's fantastic somebody's still doing
anything with the fastest thing and then
obviously on the units
switch is still so each one is in their
own little pocket
let's see to hip-hop's point let's see
some consistency right let's see some
you know what i'm saying continue joint
but to king's point it is impressive i
got i got to give king
you know you got a little moment you got
his xbox chained all he got his bling on
you're feeling good
i understand i
[Laughter]
you got to put god first thank you all
right
i love you all man i love y'all so look
i gotta get these super checks
if i don't read that i'm gonna be very
you know i'm gonna help you
yeah i'm gonna get these super chats
because it was crazy so i'm gonna go
back our apologies in advance
if i miss anybody so let's start with
gamers play hud zero
um my how the tables have turned my
glasses xbox is now becoming the world
renowned brand and asia has taken notice
welcome to the next level
then raider blade being messy with hip
hop sorry hip hop don't own
don't you own oh don't you own king's
knees
oh no no yo he he got them from what
you're gonna call it
um from from tekken but i owned him um
from xbox remember he never took that
back
i said with with that whole craig thing
and i actually saw it and
you know i was disgusted by it i was
disgusted by it because i did i was
bamboozled
like i swear to god i was upset too i
was like yo this halo what you doing
what you doing what's going on
yo i got
again raiden blade 2.2 pound hip-hop
nice intro wear those knees again okay
philly eagle five dollar super chat if
you choose to play higher or lower
difficulty that's a choice
but if you're doing a review it should
be reviewed on normal rating blade again
five pound super chat
play your game how you want it's my
money not yours therefore and i
others don't need your input on how i
play or how you play
thank you cowboys fan 404 ten dollar
super chat only thing i like
easy are my women oh my god
loose loose shout out to arcade
4247 five dollar super chat oh snap
we got what i consider royalty in here
bg
hip hop in paris let's go don't forget i
got travis standing we ain't gonna do
that
anyway
two thousand super chat you should have
colin here yes i did hit colin up he
said he was going to try to join but he
had a family function
maybe next time because i always want
people to defend himself lucious
augustus
10 super chat what about reviewing
mechanics if you played the game on easy
you don't have to understand the
mechanics in games like rpgs
depending on the genre certain
difficulties input mechanics okay
don otaku 5 super chat gameplay matters
most interviewing if they tell me they
three hit combos through the whole game
and don't tell me it's all easy that
would turn me off
fair enough we went to transparency
transparency dragon heart yobe fought
out a super chat pat
why i call him parish like the church
you made me
you made us extremely proud brother oh
during the epic
xbox presentation yes thank you peace
love life
hashtag black love salute last emperor
fought out super chat
who's to say someone having fun had an
unequal worse experience than someone
playing on hard
no one's experience should be
undervalued is what he means fair enough
that was that was bars those yeah that
was balls right there actually luca the
scum cast 20
super chat salute luka uh what's up i
personally don't have any respect for a
viewer where the reviewer admit
where the reviewer admits to play the
game more easy i don't play games on
easy and therefore the review is
worthless to me
i also don't like their arrogance
there's a choice if you ain't liked it
you ain't got to rock what it says i
feel you
uh jean-marc louis as kyle would say to
our super chat
play metro exodus on easy didn't have
the time all right fair enough that's
you
last emperor fought out of super chat
which game is really hard besides the
souls game
and the hardest difficulty on games
which none of us really play i feel you
bg but jeez
the liz of us yo last of us two play
last of us two
with our permanent perma-death mode
that's crazy the liz 22 shout out to liz
that's the clan i uh follow super chat i
agree but
full disclosure but as a consumer if you
are questioning whether to buy a product
you should look at multiple reviews
not just one fair enough no doubt that
ashley luca are back again two live
super chat to clarify
no t just shade though all right i'll
see you sis i see you i see
reggie mobile 9 sound like right man usd
10 dollar super chat
top shelf show lords every week y'all
headed out the park continues
i'm i'm back thank you brother i got you
um attic iron mike
5 super chat games like omni musha and
devil may cry would taunt you with easy
mode when you died i would never lower
my difficulty but to each their own
no big deal no doubt midway monster my
homie shot down what up
ten dollar super chat if i watch reviews
i wouldn't have a problem
with that being said for gamers like bg
he needs to preface every review oh she
needs to preference
every review with the difficulty she's
on and maybe she
should maybe should for every reveal
fair enough raiden blade two people take
over like i got it where you are
right right play uh be uh two pounds be
honest i reviewed this game on easy
done um sky lane skyland gtr 334x follow
us with chat
shout out to cogs mike the sure smp is
the true hero of the yo they
alright i stepped the game up she looted
the last day immediately it was very
good
but to be fair we're upgrading to that
michael
the lords are coming to the lords are
coming with that we can't be letting
cognito be
let me shine
also i would like to uh thank my brother
see everybody think i i run out and get
this
cod purchased this for my birthday for
your birthday bro oh
[Music]
you saw this like he could do some
shenanigans on aisles
i want him to get his bars off at his
most premium form
you know hip hop been doing it so i was
only right you know what i'm saying
yeah yo he just with the super saiyan
god
yo hip-hop it came to me in the middle
because he's like
he kept saying yo did you get your
present yet president it's gonna be
there it's gonna be there on tuesday
tuesday i get it my son when i opened it
up my son said
daddy that's amazing you know i'm gonna
have to have um
i'm gonna have to have saul pick me up a
fraud like cause you can't be the only
one with the fraud
no no it's gonna be green
no let me get a con artist
shout out follow super chat dang the
energy levels are turned way up with
this panel on the easy difficulty review
topic make sure y'all hit the like yes
thank you man we know everybody you know
where that fraud light comes from right
of them my favorite game in the whole
world
ape escape
do you see when i do this what i'm doing
like that
do y'all see where it comes from time
time all right
we got to get this time on top of the
show all right oh i'll get to century
sage and i'll let you take over after
that uh attic
since youtube sage the holy father super
chat
i was apparently too aggressive and
wanted way too much smoke on twitter
so they permanently banned my disruptive
behind but it's good to see you
in here brother we miss you salute
that's my e3 brethren
how did i know you'd get banned
eventually saying yeah i know that about
that yeah let's uh put this
in the chat yeah we got a lot let let's
let's put it into the bushes for uh
sage's uh twitter in that chat listen we
got almost 700 people here let's get
those
likes up man premium car you're having
fun positivity
come on yo we got epic stuff over here
yo this is the champion bro with mr
irishman's uh
uh come joining the realm we we need we
need seven more because the people
couple people joined the patriots oh
yeah
by the way little man is coming yes we
didn't forget y'all a little man it's
coming
no doubt hey yo i'm gonna tell y'all
this too just real quick yeah what's up
we got to do this in person
yo that's what we saw okay we already
we'll talk about that but we got to get
it done
i gotta go yeah i know i got the man up
you got it let me continue
twitter twitter british insults means
foul
oh twitter i don't know man look when it
comes to different languages
you gotta find out from the last emperor
he
has anyone ever went through a souls
game or hardest
uh the hardest difficulty and didn't die
if you did i can't respect your opinion
respectively
okay okay all right we gotta find out
some traffic
i don't know man i don't know we're
gonna move on though okay
we got a five dollar super chat from e
murray so
i ubisoft and activision are working on
a tom glancy call of duty
really wow i don't know man but we're
going to keep going man
uh we got a ten dollar super chat from
sage
in my view it's hard to trust a review
if you can't trust a person and their
tastes
you can't have folks reviewing game
anime inspired games
if they don't like anime same for
turn-based
rpgs yeah they should stay if they're a
fan of the genre i guess so we got it
we got to find out we gotta fight super
chat from raven blade
this dude be somebody was right yeah i
used to read reviews from edge game
master
and cvg back when you had writers you
can trust
even uh richard betta richard ledbetter
uh from sega saturn magazine that
predates me man that predates me
we got a two super shot from raid and
blade now i hardly care about reviews
anymore
shout out man shout out got five dollar
super superchat from lucious
i'm not butchering that last name we're
going to move on with just the first
thing
the biggest issues is having someone
review a game or a genre that they are
uh they aren't good at or don't know
they'd be killing game scores because
they don't understand i agree that is
it's like i said the review process
entirely needs to be restructured
we got a five dollar super chat we'll
debate you whoa
time we got five more debates
i miss the days of reviewing spitting up
the sections of a game like gameplay
presentation
sound they keep on consolidating it more
and more go to acg if you like stuff
like that man he's a great
reviewer for stuff yeah
brooklyn stand up shout out to my
legendary homies you should be able to
play games the way you want to
and reviewers have to be transparent at
all times that is fact
brooklyn we got to find out superchat
from underground gamer
how did a console with no games outsell
y'all
maybe it was that fire e3 show pawnee
say
didn't matter no more uh wb
g uh i i don't know wbg podcast i think
that's dirty in them oh dirty yeah
said it's really disregarded somebody
got murdered but then they were
what's going on they send their gods
we gotta fight super chat from uh space
least fry i love that name
dude you can read that you can read it
it's basically sprockets shout out with
that i think it's five dollar cad maybe
canadian anyway imagine a couple of them
actually i got it
i got you brother imagine the xbox sales
if they didn't have to siphon off
manufactured series x chipsets to their
server blade oh here's all the supply
constraints
no doubt and then raiden blade or two
pound guess what
and did this with no exclusives wow
smitty smith is that a brag yeah that's
clear
it's super flexible oh my gosh smitty
smith that's the last one i got on two
dollar super chat
we all natty over here the book of eggs
all right i got that let me just check
the last thing we got
five super chat from lord roughness
roughness all
takeovers have to start somewhere and
this one for xbox started when they
flexed
seven point five billion on cinemax that
from otaku hip-hop living in 2021
king living in 20 31.
savage messi they love the smoke they
love them too with
has next-gen games out right now i'm
pretty sure that was hitting you king
but we're gonna kick
kick
[Laughter]
i got the first name man king has point
though microsoft is now behind xbox they
will push it to win and have the ability
to execute
okay all right press that what does that
execute 99 with yeah
yeah we got a five dollar strip jam from
black ronin 3557
ratchet looks good graphically but it's
do-rags no
waves wombat jumping through portals
like contesting y'all hype for disney xd
storylines yo he messy shout out shout
out oh
shout out to their rift uh two pounds
from chat
give an xbot an inch and they take a
mile get em hip hop
yo that was smoke he was riding for
hip-hop for that he i like that
he was giving him something yeah yeah he
came he came to let him know
you got philly eagle going to get his it
uh two pounds two dollars from chat
netflix games
no thanks yeah we're probably going to
skip that yeah um
we got to fight out the troopers from
otaku forza horizon 5 is more oppressive
than rift apart
and this it is a cross gin game before
the next gen engine
seven hour tech demo versus an infinite
open world
but it's not here though if the world
ends tomorrow
ratchet is outdoor i'm done the wise old
game of final super chat i disagree with
king phil knows that if sony went away
it would create a power vacuum in gaming
also let's see
let's step right in let's see the mpd
with sony show their hair
okay so you saw what hand you saw here
out so check this out for real like you
got to show me something first because i
got stuff out there
something you have a link to something
yo let me check you out if you nice like
that
make a battle and have fun but then we
can also talk some business
so i'm telling you right now if you're
not just like that i support you you
know where i'm at
so he outside okay
don't do a video on twitter and hit tag
him yeah
hip-hop in the joint that you got so he
could see the bars and trust me if you
fire hip-hop and give it up if you fire
yo we can talk man like i don't brag
about nothing but it's a little i'm
connected
hip-hop will clap back too yeah oh yeah
i butchered that we're going along with
it no no you got it we need a king and
hip-hop
show facts
xbox to the great white hope oh my god
what's going on
hustle and motivate 2.000 shout out to
travis
he is extremely insightful yeah
definitely go check out that review he
wrote on
sword man i ain't ready yet because i'm
trying to boycott
all skyward sword no doubt so uh you
know but definitely go check that out
the riff two pal super chat love to show
y'all but king be capping too hard
i can say whatever i want i just told
you what happened for them
we got five
i played a game twice on hard after she
got oh my god
yo stop it wisely you oh man he got
pregnant both times
we had to start playing it
shout out to snitch ilp clan file super
chat eight months in and the ps5 still
does
not have a storage solution and sony has
become the remix
remake remake of remakes okay
king duvey file super chat with games
going straight to game pass i don't need
to read reviews i can play and review it
myself are we caught up at it because i
think
that is crazy which one's the last one
you do king duvey i think was the last
one
we had a two dollar super chat from
flames youtube didn't renew my
membership
well man you're gonna have to talk to
youtube about welcome to everyone
welcome
cleo walker uh we
only nine days away from grandfather of
all
microsoft games flight simulator
yo tag me the bars listen let me tell
you something
like just so you can understand for real
like
like if y'all think y'all really really
really nice
we're going to put that to the test show
me the bars
yes you'll be able to take this to a
whole nother level my name is my name
for a reason
marlon boy you don't want to follow my
name
like like i'll be around
the battle rap community like he is you
know what and actually i i got a chance
anyway move it over five dollars for
nerd
uh what happened uh the other eight
months broke
he made it better he said what happened
he was talking about him you're talking
about the mp3 you have five seconds to
respond five what happened another eight
months
yeah okay nintendo was winning
the reason ratchet and clank didn't get
talked about is because sony games
are hurt after spending 70 dollars on a
game
and platform uh platinuming and within
two days
no doubt you know what's so funny
registered clank actually
you know how you go on your first week
sales and then your second ones drop
well actually ratchet and clay did what
56 joint did it
actually went up they hit number one
like
post up again five five dollars super
chat
i have watched this show but i really do
this post up you're gonna have to give
attack under these balls
the netflix thing netflix getting into
gaming i'll just make my comment real
quick
um yeah it looks like um they got this
uh excuse me former ea oculus
exec to lead video game effort his name
is mike for do he's joining as
vp of game development and um yeah looks
like netflix is getting
in the game he apparently was a former
exec who had experience with mobile
gaming
companies like zynga ran ea mobile for a
year and most recently has been working
at facebook uh
acquiring a series of occurs game
developers like big box vr
maker of population one tiger travis is
laughing so i'm gonna let him go
what's going on with this how you
feeling real quick quick quick hit
topic last topic oh no sorry i was
laughing because somebody super chatted
poor travis looked like the odd one at a
cookout
yo he's still invited to the barbecue
he's still here
you know what i've been looking at this
whole time the pictures behind you
travis thank god
all i was going to say is i i actually
think that netflix is probably
not going to be competing in the gaming
space a lot of people are assuming i
think they're probably going to make
mobile games that you can
play on the netflix app on your phone
and then the rest will be like fmv stuff
like bandersnatch i i don't think that
they're gonna
sell you a netflix controller or uh i
think the console
i think it's gonna be i think it's gonna
be like in the realms of like
maybe the walking dead they'll do a
little bit of that like because they
there's some of them already on there so
i think they're going to stick to
a lot of interactive stories on on
netflix
no doubt hip-hop yeah netflix in the
game what you thinking
i'm gonna tell you someone tell you
something like very interesting
like how this popped up so i do work
with netflix
you understand what i'm saying like i
like i'm not giving a scoop
exclusive so so the thing is like like
you know i do a lot of interviews with
you know many different type of actors
oh yeah yeah yeah facts oh yeah and you
just say something
with an olympian dominique dawes so
shout out to dominic
that was great so i do interviews with
all types of people
all the time so i'm talking to pr
publicists all types of things so
here's what i can say at least for right
now that's right
so um the whole netflix gaming thing um
they had uh uh i think this was at e3 in
2019
if i'm not mistaken they was talking
about the stranger things and all this
other stuff
like with netflix right so they've been
working on
a gaming division for quite some time
now
now what i will tell you and i can't
confirm this yet but i'm working okay
but either playstation or xbox
supposed to be working something to
where they can have you know
movies games and tv shows everything
all in one for one price so this is what
this is what netflix is trying to do so
it's not so much of netflix
just trying to add value to netflix it's
about what netflix can add to
one of the console manufacturers so that
right there
came up in a conversation that's all i
can say i don't know if they did a deal
or not
all i know is that a unification of
taking all the properties of netflix
and all the properties of playstation or
xbox in terms of the games that they
have when you look at playstation now as
a service and everything
what does that look like if it was
united together for one price
now though there was leaning more
towards playstation because sony has
their
motion pictures right right and it's
supposed to be it
now listen they have a deal i think they
did a deal with somebody
no but check this out sony has
funimation crunchyroll
you know but they have all these they
don't have crunchyroll yet but they're
still in the process
well yeah yeah most likely it seems like
that's what they're gonna have
so between all of these things um it
will give netflix
a competitive edge against every
everybody that they're going against
right
if they partner with sony to get sony's
licenses on movies and
shows and things like that netflix is
really trying to compete with anime too
like they're real yeah they're doing a
great job yeah yes so i'm just letting
you know
those was the talks that has happened
and i know this because whenever these
things are
uh being generated we get hit up with
information
in terms of who we have to interview
about them okay not fair enough
that's all i can say right now i respect
you on that man definitely did not know
that this is a that's a great nugget
salute to you on that that that's what's
up
um attic king real quick um i don't care
okay yeah it doesn't care moving on
shout out to netflix man netflix amazon
amazon the only thing i want from
netflix is seven deadly since part two i
don't give two
snaps about any gaming from them fair
enough
okay amazon has luma luna or something
like that
and um then you have stadia from google
that we already know what happened there
yeah um
it was it was a huge success right yeah
it was fantastic it was so
successful i foreshadowed the demise
from
the door and they did the same thing you
did like uh
uh netflix is doing right now taking
establishments
setting them up into a position for stop
feeding into a trap
but i feel that this is if they don't
partner with
um sony and i don't think it's viable
for them to partner with microsoft
i don't think microsoft adds any value
to netflix
right and that's just my opinion of it
but sony's um
background in movies is sony's
background in
all the media ips that they they do uh
contribute to like crunchyroll and stuff
like that that they will have acquired
those things the last of us is being on
a netflix
i think they already had a deal with
netflix i have to go back and look at my
notes again
but i i believe that they did a deal
with netflix in that
whole thing i didn't know if it
encompassed video games
but the video games could be on the back
end of that if they're doing that
because
what does uh netflix get with partnering
with playstation for playstation now
putting netflix in there
that makes it an attractive buy when you
go to netflix and you can also click on
the playstation now app that because
those games are there
i think that makes that an extremely
extremely dangerous player when it comes
to video games because
netflix is in everybody's home in
everybody's phone
and in everybody's space so if you can
put playstation
in the same places and make it
synonymous with netflix
i believe that's how you achieve
dominance in a space
that you were not in previously oh my
god
yeah yeah
the way you broke that down was fire
that was fine yeah yeah he was just
correct now i'm just thinking about
business-wise money-wise yeah yeah
money-wise i'm gonna sit there and i'm
gonna break it down how it is money-wise
money-wise it makes no sense from
microsoft and it makes complete sense
for sony yeah no it is what it is look
it's interested in getting into the
space
um all i'm curious about is the
distribution you know as far as the
games the interface what type of games
they're gonna do
look they've already got you know the
service you know it's everywhere
the question is going to be how serious
it is i definitely was curious to see if
uh
sony and them actually kind of got
together or something like that
yeah troops go we're going to see you
know we're going to see how serious it
is but it was interesting shout out to
saul for bringing the topic let's get
these super chats we get out of here
because we went crazy oh my god
oh god uh he read the the poor travis so
five dollar super chat from cowboy fan
404
what travis and addicts see each other
at a black cookout
they give each other that knob
i would not give you the head nod i
would stay as far away from you as
possible
because that's the worst thing you could
do in a black cookout
child travis one question is do you eat
chitlins
with hot sauce with hot sauce no no no
no
no no no no we don't don't you i don't
do it yeah
i can't i don't give a big either no
anton anton williams two dozen chess
someone
twerk for travis he will be happy then
what is going on all right
so listen listen listen sony pictures
made me feel like they didn't make that
move
with netflix they took their stuff from
stars to put it on netflix that's the
old pack that i was talking about oh
okay okay got you yeah all right
i'm coming together the way it seems
yeah yeah underground game of five
not sure if i can trust hip-hop as a
decided year
still waiting for ps1 the ps4 back
compat for bob you know i don't want to
delay this too much but
you want to comment on that hip-hop oh
of course
like i wish it would have already came
out already like it's taking mad long
it's it's taking man
that's his that's his rat name dawn i
think he's on platforms is that
all streaming platforms and i make my
own beats
i ain't about to be i ain't about that
battle smoke though
but i'ma hit your channel yeah hit him
up hit him up bro
hit me up son
he trying to get signed yeah
[Laughter]
there needs to be a sequel to that movie
the new guy starring travis and king
[Laughter]
all right
what they do is they do a psych sequel
travesty kid
i'm done look blue iop poll this week
going up it's on lawrencegaming.net
right now with the recent information in
spec reveal of the portable steam deck
by valve
will this affect your purchase of the
nintendo switch
oled the choices are a no switch still
has
exclusive first party games and is in a
completely different market than the
steam deck
b yes steam deck is the switch pro we
always wanted
more powerful more features and
versatile os for games
with choice c i don't care it's all fun
and game until those 720p
pc titles destroy your hard drive suit
that's gonna come out and support the
chat yo first of all
salute to the legendary hip
hop gamer on your hot 97 every day
that's about word logitech g
chain spinning one of the most
influential
con content creators i know an
inspiration inspiration for a lot of us
and honestly brother i don't get a
chance to tell you enough man
i love you bro your positive energy
truly outshines everything and i just
love what you do i love what you
represent man regard no one can ever
tell me about hip-hop game with a man
that is a real
dude support for us from day one when we
were we were literally
nothing you had no reason to come on and
you always showed us love even when we
going to conventions to shows
my bro telling people where they can
find you what you got going on now man
yo let me tell y'all right now man
before i do all of that
i love y'all and i'm thankful let me
tell you something real quick everybody
that's watching i know i gotta hurry up
cause you got to end the show
um y'all don't understand that when it
comes to this
it all stems from my grandma like i have
a different type of passion and a
different type of energy
it's never been about what i could get
what i can get what i could get i'm a bi
i'm always doing my thing but it's not
success if it's only for you
bring the home right shout out to a
rocks he told me once he said you know
he doesn't understand the gatekeeping
because he's like what's the point in
having you know the the more fame the
more money if all your friends are broke
it's what is the so my thing is when you
when anybody when you see
king when you see cog when you see attic
like when you see sovereign when you see
the whole team you know what's saying
chocolate travis is in the building
right now with his level of work
incredibly exquisite
you understand what i'm saying like when
you think about what we do
here and the entertainment that we bring
y'all it's not y'all
like just so much important to us and
everything like that but it's what you
give
us to be able to give back to y'all so
thank you so much and we love y'all for
it i love you brothers for life
love it it's an honor to be here thank
you absolutely i was so happy when you
pulled up addy told you before i was
like
juice
no doubt man and of course still in the
building
the legendary my last word can't fire
now bredren
and ign's own got a review up of skyward
sword right now
truly professional i think he's a star
he gave it a fair score and he gave it a
good start i think this kid could have
won a point lower but a fair score
he's gonna talk to the guy to actually
finish the game why don't you finish the
game
so next week are you going to are we
going to talk to the dude finishing time
i'm trying to give my bed hits flowers
right now come on now
but anyway the legendary thai guy travis
a star in the making
where can the fine people find you what
you got going on sir
yeah you can find me on twitter at ty
guy travis that's where i
usually am you can watch me on uh the
last words sometimes i'm on that show
on friday nights with really enjoyed
being on this show i've
watched you guys uh you know off and on
over the years and you're all
awesome i love you it definitely reminds
me of home
uh i've got a review coming out uh next
week for the new jrpg chris tales
um we got the code for it friday night
so i will not be making the embargo but
i'll have the review at some point uh
next week and uh
you can look for that on ign.com
nice plug brother thank you for being
your honesty
like i said just contributing to a great
debate a great
respectful debate and discussion that
everybody has a point so i loved it
i want to give two shout outs before we
get into the laws um definitely got to
shout out the legendary
gamertag radio and of course kind of
funny xcat
and the host of the microsoft but that's
the showcase paris lily
for pulling up great look man always a
pleasure to have him in here
and have his perspective and of course
legend of the game
weapon wheels finest my man bg brooklyn
stand
i remember bg for brooklyn square tree
and all that old stuff yo shout out to
bg for pulling being the villain when he
need to be the villain but being real
when he need to be real and we love
different opinions salute to him he's on
weaponry i think they're going live two
hours from now salute the weapon will
podcast the whole team
they've been putting it down for a long
time salute to them brothers they doing
anything
and uh of course man we got soft that
pulled up last minute you know what i'm
saying smooth bike and all that you know
i
said
so salute but lord attic brother i'm so
happy you could make it
i know you had a rough week and just to
see you in here
still being yourself and smiling joking
and saying that your dad
brought you your first console we want
you to be here
and i'm just happy you could make it
brother thank you so much for coming
through i love you
and we we're here for you during this
whole tough time brother you know that
i love you to death yeah you know
i definitely uh have had a rougher week
i i was considering just sleeping the
day because i
i just didn't feel like really getting
out of bed but it's like i said i
remember my dad buying the materials
mask and the expansion pass
uh it was expansion pass me expansion
slot thing for the n64
you know it was red which which i didn't
know but those things are mad expensive
now
oh yeah yeah yeah they're like 50 bucks
just for that little piece
yeah you know he bought me my first n64
he bought
he bought me glover and rogue squadron
with it
so like you know yeah so it was
definitely uh
it was a rough week but you know first
thing i want to thank is you know thanks
paris for coming on
i definitely over booked man i apologize
to this chat i brought too many people
up in here
but uh you know it was that that topic
was a very serious talk that a lot of
people have conversations with
and if we've always stated anything on
this podcast it doesn't matter who you
are we will give you a voice
and uh we wanted to make sure that paris
had that voice because he was definitely
in the chat saying he wanted to come in
so i gave that uh that outlet to him uh
you know first off i want to thank
travis for coming on yeah he still ain't
carried me through a trials run yeah i'm
still waiting
to do that definitely on him now you
know but
this dude you know you see his nail on
anything in terms of uh you know reviews
you could always guarantee you that man
played that game to his fullest anyone
that is hardcore destiny about these
sticks man he's about these sticks
can't nerf these hands
you know shout out to bg he's always
been one of the
you know one of the realest people in
the industry no matter what kind of
following you have
you know what you know what you are
yeah he always about giving people
voices even though that you know
a lot of people you know you know it's
just
bg doesn't care at all about anything he
just
he wants everyone to have their voice
and he wants a good entertaining show
so you know i appreciate that and shout
out to hip-hop man like
at the end of the day you can question
some of the things hip-hop says
but the thing that you cannot question
what hip-hop does
is the energy and the passion he brings
to the industry second and i've always
said
it does it doesn't matter what people
say unless they're saying off the wall
stuff that they really shouldn't be
saying
it matters the energy and the love they
have for this
industry because we're all in the
industry and you see this dude
every time i see him it's like he's like
an energizer bunny man
like i don't have the energy to match
him i never do i never will
but i appreciate him coming on then
shout out to you know saul for
for doing what you can you know he got
he got pulled away at the last minute
look at the double shot
and you know i i want us you know shout
out to the chat man you guys are in here
like almost 800 deep
uh you know you guys really i think we
can't get mad we call our friends why
you ain't pull up
oh yeah yeah we cut them off you all
support us
you're watching me and we got you know
we're up to what's up number 12 live
we're up to
six more members or patrons we need for
the next stream
we had some people do patreon during the
podcast and we had five new members so
you guys are showing up
with that man you know it's like like
like i said in the patreon stuff and i
put it on
we're going to be doing another
different type of podcast now we're
gonna have to talk
amongst each other now let me get this
straight this is going to be behind
members and the patreon the reason that
we're doing that
is because it's not gaming related it's
not really our brand
but we've gotten so much feedback from
the community that they want to know
us outside of gaming yes so you know
what we're going to do is we're going to
put that on the
the tears on members and patreon uh
what what we'll do is maybe twice to
once a month
we ain't got the logistics we'll reach
out to the community and we'll say yo
ask us questions and we'll answer them
and we'll pre-record and we'll put it on
those prospective platforms
and the reason we can do stuff like that
is because of the support that all of
you give us
factual we always give it right back to
the community and of course
the access game a tremendous message
please if you guys haven't seen i might
play it at the end
as well you know for for a little the
little princess you know i'm saying on
her dream
you know what i'm saying king you know
what i'm saying is a seed and i'm so
proud of her
to see what she's doing so i'm glad we
were able to do that little support i'll
run it again
yeah so that people can see what's okay
and it's like at the end of the day man
like can you
gotta give props to you man and in this
world
so many decisions you you made the right
decisions and you raised such a great
person that they made the right
decisions
because it easily could go the other way
you should really give a pat on your
back for that and let's help her achieve
her dream you know what i'm saying
do what she's doing so king floyd's
yours what you got going on salute to
your messiness in the uh xbox npd
okay we're gonna talk about that in a
second but i want to say
uh travis i never got a chance to tell
you like um
when cog i watch the last word and then
you'll be on the last word
that's i really like that guy i really
like
multiple people told me that you know
what's funny travis the moment that
that uh you know shout out to fire uh
that was a great podcast but the moment
that i was told that you know you guys
are doing seasonal
with the big events i was like i was
like you need to find out what you're
traveling
he did so yeah so when when i saw you
there and i'm like oh man
and then you know to see that in the
group and i was like man it's fantastic
then
to see that you were coming on today i
was really excited for that
you know because um contrary to popular
belief i do
actually look at things due to the
backgrounds and i actually check people
out
so i do like your stuff no doubt all
right
regardless of where you are i'd rather
have you at larger gaming.net
tremendous work and a tremendous person
your integrity is second to none that's
what i respect most
because like you said you weren't
finished with it and you're going to
give the review
in progress and then we gave a second
review and you saw that you were
rewarded for your honesty your
transparency
and again they came back to see it again
the second review so that's that was
beautiful and i'm glad that you shared
that with people because maybe that
one reviewer right now that's reviewing
the game that's under that pressure
that's afraid to do that maybe you just
gave them a little something to
do that shout out to you to just you
know be honest and tell them if you're
not gonna make you not maybe they're
scared they're gonna get fired or
something i don't know respect right
um i want to give a shout out to
sovereign uh for coming through
i understand what he's going through it
seems like uh
new york is like a whole new flood area
and oh
yeah you saw the train station right
here
in the floods it's crazy it's kind of
crazy it's crazy
so he works in a situation where it's in
like a little flood zone so
he's working overtime and it's really
nuts but he actually jumped on
um i've been trying to you know to keep
contact with him during the week because
i know this process is very hard and him
laying in the bed and saying he did not
want to get i'm so happy he did get up
because depression hits people
in different forms and this is a
situation that can hit you
like a ton of bricks so i am very happy
that you did get up i'm very happy that
you are president like hip-hop told you
in the beginning
you are loved and you have a great
support system around you
um hip-hop my man
my brother for life you're not applicant
i'm gonna tell you
and and i don't guess i guess people
because they see us go at each other we
new york that's what happens
that's what happens that's it that's
dude you know yeah yeah
you are the most giving without asking
individual facts
in my life wow whatever bro
ever that's crazy i was sitting there
watching tv
and you know my girl was next to me and
you called
pause the movie and i'm talking she's
like oh
oh you know because she had you know you
you know you look they look like what
was that
i was like no he just called to tell me
he loved me that's fine
he just he just felt it right there and
that's who you are that's who you've
always been
same person you know and i truly respect
it that's why
you are who you are you understand
and and your name carries that weight of
that respect
facts and that's a beautiful thing
that's a beautiful thing to see
um i want to give a shout out to paris
yes
for coming through and speaking his
piece and
and doing it eloquently yes the same way
he stepped on that microsoft stage
he carries himself with that regalness
and i i respect it and i love
it and everybody had a uh a different
view on certain things but we were
able to have a conversation that was
respectful
to every individual
i want to give a shout out to bg mm-hmm
it's only him and fawns that i will do
their shows after i do this morning
shout out to gtl live
shout out because
i respect bg i respect everything she
does and i respect that he
sometimes he knows that his opinion will
be the bad guy but he's okay
with wearing the bad guy but he's not a
rude bad guy
and his and his opinion is rooted in his
truth
yeah so if you have a problem with his
truth that's you
but that's his truth so i respect him
for walking the line and being who he is
it was a great show today you already
know i'm
super proud of you thank you always
every day i
i i i look at defining duke and i look
at the i'm like oh i love this guy
oh i look at my chain i'm like
i had to bless the whole but um okay we
have electro
up electro is the next one up and i'm
gonna give you a story that y'all don't
know about
because this dude is probably my
favorite
spider-man villain i don't know
really about him but you don't know why
he's my favorite villain
all right but i'm gonna tell you what i
did to try to be electro
and jamie situation
and you gonna figure it out y'all don't
really
real quick just like fun fact for those
that don't know
that's how i got the scar on my lip when
i was one years old i got electrocuted
oh my god with a refrigerator cord i bit
a refrigerator cord
as a baby so thank god i'm alive my god
you're alive
yeah so that's how i got the skull oh
you're trying to turn into jamie foxx
for real i just tried
super powers
y'all messy your messy salute
okay
we have a ton of writers and hopefully
we got travis next
traffic
johnson
[Applause]
this man this business acumen is always
on point
salute look man fantastic show love all
y'all man again hip hop
the legend salute brother paris
everybody that pulled up bg
solved the whole bit travis in the
building see you friday sir we're going
to read you super chats and then get up
out of here
i got gaming forte fought out on super
chat he's like i guess
i'll contribute to the one hour
scripture reading of super chats love
the support of this community and keep
being the best podcast on sunday my
brother
forte at the dps podcast go subscribe to
them they go every thursday him and slow
mo backslap
um dragonheart yobe follow superchat
shout out to hip hop gamer
he had me excited for the new wwe 2k15
back then when it was first announced
thank you man
salute it's all williams two dollar
super chat that blood rag
aim is perfect for x cloud king then um
i believe
decade damn it skip for a little bit
decade decado
find out what your ilp is worth the
laugh of sleep between two 12 hour
shifts on a sunday
salute oh then we got my man max city
entertainment 5
super chat over 200 days plus still
ps5 ssd expansion still locked
ask sony for better he'd be a messy on
the way out the door oh
big city sounds like a yu-gi-oh place
facts shout out the big cloud gaming
oh big cloud of the village playstation
damn i'm late salute to the lord you
good brother you here was a fantastic
discussion again
salute the big kyle gamer go subscribe
to his channel giving you a lot of great
playstation news
you already know and last but not least
i think tony bryant found out super chat
travis has been on my must-watch loss
list since the mass effect debate show
god got a galaxy to save ain't nobody
got time for love though those were his
bars remember that travis
those are your balls that was awesome
and real quick before we go man yeah
go over there and show our our dude fawn
some love man
look everybody peace of blessing sunday
yo this was a lit show i love you all we
got more fun things planned everybody
enjoy
i'm gonna leave you all with a message
from the king please support this is
important
okay what's once again tell them uh
i'll peace obviously
peace and blessings uh i bring you great
news
you know a lot of times uh we're talking
about video games or we're talking about
combat sports we're talking about
wonderful statues
today i'm talking to you about life i'm
talking to you
about the stuff that matters most to
parents
right the stuff that matters most to
parents is their children
the seed of their loins
[Music]
the fruit from the tree
and what parents want for their children
or what every parent should want for
their children is for their children to
succeed
at the highest level since my daughter's
been born
i changed the way i did things that i
changed the way i
thought i changed the way i operated
to fit around this wonderful new life
that was in my life and
she did such a phenomenal job growing
up to the adult that she is now
when she graduated
i was elated when she was born i was
elated
i had purpose
[Music]
she has always been a shining light a
great kid and she started out on
her first job but let's back it up just
a little bit
she wants to be like a dad
a entrepreneur go out
start your own business be the captain
of your own ship
so she has a love for baking
and she's going to the culinary
institute
of america i'm so ecstatic
she graduated with a 4.0 gpa
and she's going
to do and follow her dreams she says
daddy
she wants to own home bakery she loves
to make cupcake cakes and
yes we are the guinea pigs yes
we try everything and we encourage her
and push her through so now she has her
first job
and she works for cutco
she's doing her passion
cut cutco sells
fine cutlery and
it's amazing of course she would be
doing something
that is linked to what
she truly is to become
[Music]
so this is where you guys come in and
this is where i need you guys
help because
we all want our children to succeed
because i was one of her uh clients
so what you do is you go to your
iphone or your google app
and you go and you download cutco
and her reference number was that number
that you saw the whole time
that was up at the top and you go and
you put in her reference number
and do me a favor schedule an interview
sit down even if you don't buy anything
she's working on her
skills that she would need to succeed in
life
conversational skills selling skills
being endeared to the customer type of
skills
she's working on skills that will
forever
better herself so please
take the time out do that
and you're doing me a favor you're doing
us a favor
but you're also helping her build and
succeed
in life and it's all we want as parents
thank you again it's lord king david
giving you a little bit something
different
than just what we do when we do our
hobbies
[Music]
these are our hobbies she's my life